This is Jocko podcast number 56 with Echo Charles and me,
Jocko Willink.
Good Evening Echo,
good evening,
silent screams and broken dreams.
Addicts,
junkies,
pushers and feens.
Crowded spaces and sad faces.
Never looked back as the police chase us.
Consumed slowly by chaos,
a victim of the streets,
hungry for knowledge,
but afraid to eat a life of destruction.
It seems no one cares.
A man child alone with burdens to bear
trapped in a life of crime and hate.
It seems the ghetto will be my fate if I had just one wish,
it would surely be that God would send angels to set me free.
Free from the madness of a city running wild,
free from the life of a ghetto child.
And that is a poem written by a young Deon,
dre McCullough,
a criminal drug dealer who when he wrote that Poe poem was doing time
after being one of the main subjects in a book called the corner,
which is written by David Simon and Edward Burns,
which documents the violent drug trade in Baltimore,
Maryland.
And that Sorta morphed into an HBO series that was called the corner as well,
which paved the way for another series,
which is called the wire,
which is just an outstanding mini series that came out on Hbo.
But the wire is his fictional,
even though it's based on kind of the same situation in Baltimore,
but the corners real,
the book,
the corner is real and it gives a very clear any very grim view at the life of
drugs and crime in the inner city,
namely in Baltimore.
And I'm going to go back to the book now.
We can't stop it.
Not with all the lawyers,
guns and money in this world,
not with guilt or morality or righteous indignation,
not with crime summits or task forces or committees,
not with policy decisions made in places that can't be seen from the last corner
of Fayette and Monroe.
No lasting victory in the war on drugs can be bought by doubling the number of
beat cops or tripling the number of prison beds.
No peace can come from kingpin statutes and civil civil forfeiture laws and
warrantless searches and whatever the hell else is about to be tossed into neck
next year's crime bill down on fifth street.
They know today and has on every other day.
The shop will be open by mid morning and the touts will be on the corners,
chirping out product names as if the stuff is street legal.
The runners will bring a little more of the package down in the feens will queue
up to be served align of gaunt,
passive supplicants stretching down the alley and around the block.
The corner is rooted in human desire,
crude and certain and immediate.
And the hard truth is that all the law enforcement in the world can't mess with
desire down at Fayette and Monroe and every corner like it in Baltimore,
the dealers and feeds have one because they aren't legion.
They've won because the state of Maryland and the federal government have in
prison thousands and arrested tens of thousands and put maybe 100,000 on parole
and probation roles and still it isn't close to enough by raw demographics.
The men and women of the corners can claim victory in Baltimore alone.
A city of fewer than 700,000 souls with some of the highest recorded rates of
intravenous drug use in the nation.
They are 50 perhaps 60,000 strong.
Three of them available for every prison bed in the entire state of Maryland.
The slingers,
our manning,
more than hundred open air corners serving up the product as fast as they can
get it off the southbound metro liner and the Feans are chasing down that blast.
24 seven
in neighborhoods with where no other wealth exists.
They've constructed an economic engine so powerful that they'll readily
sacrifice everything to it.
Yeah,
and make no mistake,
that engine is humming.
No slacking profit margins,
no recessions,
no bad quarterly reports,
no layoffs,
no naturalized unemployment rate.
Get it straight.
They're not just out here to sling and shoot drugs in drug market and s in
cities across the nation lives without any obvious justification are given
definition through a simple self sustaining capitalism.
The corner has a place for them.
Every last soul touts,
runners look outs,
mules,
stick up,
boys,
stash dealers and forcers,
feens burn artists,
police,
snitches,
all necessary in the world of the corner.
Each is to be used,
abused,
and ultimately devoured with unfailing precision.
It's about the feens thousands of them who want that good dope.
They need it the way other souls need to breathe air.
It's about the slingers,
the young crews working the packages,
all of them willing to trade a morality that they've never seen or felt for a
fleeting moment of material success.
They're working the package with the hidden knowledge that they will fall,
that with rare exception,
the money won't last and the ride will be over in six months or four or three.
Violence.
Violence is no longer the prerogative of the professional,
but a function of impulse and emotion.
The contract killers and the well-planned assassinations of earlier areas are
mere myth on these corners.
Now the moment of truth generally comes down to some man child with hurt
feelings waving of 380 or a 38 around spraying bullets up and down the block.
The accidental shooting of by standards is now common place.
Okay.
Even 15 year old hoppers have loaded 38 it's hidden in the alley.
The job is a little better than a deaf
wish,
and in the end,
the corner best serves the hardcore,
the hardcore,
the junk yard dogs with neither the time nor the inclination for pity.
The corner proves itself every day.
It destroys whatever it touches.
Okay?
Eventually the corner destroyed de Andre Mccullough,
even though he received the second chance in his life,
and he actually got to play a small role in that series that came out on Hbo.
The wire,
you've got some other jobs in the entertainment industry as well,
but the corner called them back.
And that guy,
the Andre who wrote that poem,
he ended up dead of a heroin overdose in 2012 at the age of 35
no,
there's a reason I'm bringing this up and that is because we have a guest
tonight,
a guest that is actually more responsible for this podcast than anyone,
and we'll get to that later.
Yeah,
but his name is Peter Attia and he grew up a boxer.
It's been a long distance endurance athlete,
God,
his degree in medical engineering and applied mathematics and then got his
doctorate as an MD from Stanford
and did his residency in surgery.
And the reason that I started off this whole
talk about the corner is because he did that residency at a place called job
John Hopkins Hospital,
which is about three miles from the actual corner of Fayette and Monroe Street,
the war zone that's pictured in the book,
the place where de Andre Macola lived and were violence was and in many ways
still is just a part of life and Peter was at ground zero in the war zone and
saw more darkness and suffering probably than any person should have to
and learned a lot from it
and we're going to get to that in a bit,
but first of all,
Peter Attia,
welcome to the show.
Thank you for having me,
sir.
Glad to have you on finally
and
you grew up.
We'll get,
we'll get right into it.
You grew up.
Tell us a little bit about just growing up,
you grew up in Canada and I know you've covered it.
For those of you that haven't listened to the Tim Ferriss has interview with
you,
listen to them,
what does that,
three of them?
Yeah,
I think so.
I think there's three of them.
You can listen to those and get more details on,
you know,
Peter,
his whole background.
But for those that are just listening right now,
you grew up in Canada.
Just a little,
little s little statement about that.
Yeah,
I grew up in Toronto.
Um,
you know,
immigrant parents,
so grew up,
you know,
sort of in the wonderful lower middle class,
uh,
not the best suburb of Toronto.
The Toronto,
like New York has five boroughs,
four of them are nice.
One of them is not.
I grew up in the one that's not so nice.
Um,
and uh,
meaning it's just a dump and nodded like it's,
you know,
it's not like a war zone or anything.
Um,
and I have lived now in the United States for about half of my life.
So I,
high school in college was in Canada.
And then everything from med school beyond has been here and I am now a dual
citizen.
How did that transition work?
Cause you didn't you,
you obviously got applied mathematics degree and then you worked in the civilian
world a little while with that degree,
right?
Yeah.
So,
uh,
my plan was always to do a phd in aerospace engineering.
Um,
and so I,
that's why I did the mechanical engineering and applied math.
I did the two things for Undergrad.
Got It.
And then was sort of just in the,
almost about ready to go and start that phd in aerospace.
And then I had just a complete change of heart and decided I wanted to go into
medicine.
And so that,
so what I had to do for a year then was you've got to take this thing called the
MCAT,
which of course I didn't have any of the courses to take it.
So I had to sort of teach myself the chemistry and biology that summer took the
m cat.
Okay.
But then I still had times,
that's what I do in the summertime.
It's,
I'll,
I'll teach myself,
you know,
chemistry and biology.
I didn't,
I didn't do that well.
And then,
uh,
and then I had to do what's called a post back here where you go back and you're
in the process of applying to medical school without actually having the courses
to get in.
So if you get in it's conditional.
And,
and so that year,
because I'd already graduated,
I just taught calculus.
Um,
so I,
you know,
was like a,
adjunct lecturer at the university and taught calculus,
which I always enjoy it.
I mean,
cause I taught it for a couple of years before and so and so that's why you're
waiting to get into med school applying and then,
and getting my courses,
like I forget what I had to take biology and psychology.
Biochemistry had to take a few prerequisites to get it because in engineering
and math I'd never taken a single course.
In fact,
the day before I took the MCAT,
this,
this is only going to be funny for Geeks who get biology.
So I'll clarify in a moment.
But I'm studying for the MCAT this summer that I'm supposed to take the test and
the whole time I'm studying,
I'm like,
you know,
I can't believe how sloppy these textbooks are.
They keep confusing meiosis and mitosis.
Like why can't they just spell it the same way?
Both times?
Like they,
I didn't realize that it was two separate things.
Right.
My ocs is when a cell separates,
Brits doesn't replicate its DNA might host sees is when it creates an equal
copy.
And I literally not until the day before the m cat realized that those were two
separate things.
I mean,
that's how,
that's how clueless I was going into this test.
It was lucky reason I knew that was because I was helping one of my daughters
studied for their biology something.
Anybody who took any biology course should know that,
but I hadn't taken any so and so then you get into med school.
Yeah.
You go there.
What's that?
Four years.
Another four years of school.
Huh.
And then you get done with that and now it's time to do your residency.
So you do,
you get to pick where you're going to go.
Not sort of,
so it's a funny system called the match system.
So when you're in your,
that's your beginning,
your fourth year of medical school.
By that point you have to figure it out.
What you want to do.
Do you want to be a surgeon?
Do you want to be an internist?
You want to be a pediatrician or radiologist,
whatever you want to do.
Cause all of those have different programs and then you have to apply to those
programs.
So let's say you wanted to do orthopedic surgery,
you would send out your application to all the orthopedic programs in the
country.
Hopefully you'd get interviews to a good number of them.
You'd go do the interviews and then you would submit to a match system,
a rank order of the places you'd want to go.
And you don't put something on there that you don't want to take.
So if you,
if you inner,
you know,
if you applied to 30 programs,
you got interviewed at 15 and you liked the 10 you rank those 10 in order.
Similarly,
the programs,
after they interview everybody do the same exercise.
They do the rank.
Hmm.
And then a computer matches you one-to-one.
That's actually pretty squared away.
Yeah.
So you,
the only way you're going to guarantee you know where you're going is rank one
program and hope you get it.
All right.
So,
um,
in my case,
I forgot,
I think I ranked five programs,
um,
and I ranked,
Johns Hopkins first for surgery,
not because I want it to live in Baltimore though in many ways I think it was a
blessing to do so.
But you know,
because at the time,
I don't know that this is true today,
but at the time it was probably the best general surgery training program in the
country.
And that was a combination of two things.
One is you had these kind of legendary surgeons there that had pioneered some of
the most complicated,
what are called hepatic biliary surgeries,
surgeons,
surgery of the pancreas and the liver and stuff like that.
But at the same time,
as you alluded to,
it was in a war zone.
And so the other aspect of training to be a good surgeon is having great
exposure to penetrating trauma.
So trauma,
you always want to divide into blunt and penetrating blunt trauma is not often
operative.
So people that get hit by cars and things like that,
you know,
ends up being more orthopedic.
But if you're a general surgeon and you need to be able to cut open the chest
and the abdomen and things like that,
it's penetrating trauma.
It's,
it's,
you want knife and gun fight.
Um,
not that you want it,
but that's,
that's the training ground to be.
And so,
and,
and Sorta Baltimore would have been,
you know,
probably in the top five.
What year was this?
2000 2001.
Yeah,
2003.
Okay.
And
when you were,
what was it,
what was the thing that slipped,
or if this is going backwards a little bit,
what was the thing that transitioned in your mind where you all of a sudden
wanting to do medicine?
Well,
yeah,
it's funny.
I don't think I've ever talked about this publicly.
Um,
so when I was in engineering school,
I,
uh,
in my second year,
I started doing some volunteer work.
Um,
and I this the reason why is too complicated,
but I started volunteering with,
uh,
some kids that were in,
in a,
in a shelter that had been abused.
So is,
it is a home for sexually abused kids.
And that got me interested in sort of volunteering in a hospital.
So I was volunteering at a hospital that,
um,
had,
you know,
it was a pediatric cancer ward,
so you would just sort of,
you know,
you'd go up there and you'd kind of hang out with kids and just play with them
and stuff like that.
And so between that experience,
and then I was still doing this volunteer work with these kids who had been
sexually abused.
A lot of those kids were suicidal.
So I also found myself in the hospital a lot with these kids after they'd
attempted to kill themselves.
And I think somewhere in my senior year of engineering,
I kind of had this,
you know,
I,
I don't know what the word is.
You know,
I don't think it's an existential crisis as much as maybe a nervous breakdown,
but just a bunch of things.
We're kind of going on probably some undiagnosed psychiatric issues on my part.
But I realized like
I love engineering and math intellectually,
but I,
there's no emotional connection outside of the joy of solving a problem,
which by the way is probably plenty enough.
But I wondered if there was something else that I'd be more interested in that
could scratch two itches,
right?
It could scratch sort of the intellectual itch,
but also maybe an emotional itch.
And so I spent the majority of my senior year thinking about was there something
else I ought to do?
Um,
but I'd been successful in,
in my undergrad.
So it was sort of a given that,
you know,
if you're going to graduate at the top of your class,
you're going to go off and do the best phd program.
So at the very end,
when I sort of declined to do that and I turned down a bunch of scholarships,
um,
it seemed a little odd that I would go and do medicine.
But,
but that's really the reason.
It was,
you know,
it was kind of this epiphany I had one day actually while I was in the hospital
and I was sort of had this actually,
it's really funny,
we've just moved as were talking about earlier and you know,
one of the things moving is great for is cleaning up stuff and actually found my
essay that I wrote when I applied to medical school back in,
you know,
whatever,
95 or 96.
And uh,
it was really interesting to go back and read the story because it's exactly
kind of how I remembered it.
Right.
Which was like this moment I had this sort of insight,
that is what I want it to do.
So,
um,
so that's,
that's kind of the,
the,
the series of events that led me to have that seemingly orthogonal change in
direction.
Right.
Okay.
So now you go through that,
you end up,
you get your excepted,
the residency at John John Hopkins,
you show up there.
What's that like?
Well,
I remember when I interviewed at Hopkins for Medical School as well.
Um,
and I,
I was lucky enough to get in there for medical school and at the time I think
Hopkins was technically the best medical school in the country.
I think it was Harvard and Hopkins were the best two.
And Stanford was,
you know,
maybe third,
fourth,
fifth.
But I remember when I interviewed there for medical school at the end of the
interview,
like I had to spend a night there.
And so they put us up in the dorms for the Med students,
which great idea you get to meet your upper classmates.
And I remember I said that that Friday night I said,
hey,
I'm going to go walk down to the harbor.
It's like a mile and a half down the road.
And they were like,
oh no,
you can't do that.
I said,
what do you mean?
He said,
you,
you can't walk outside of the hospital.
And then they pointed out that on every corner there was like a booth with an
armed guard.
There's a garden full armor with a,
an automatic weapon.
And so I remember at the time thinking,
yeah,
I probably don't want to go here for med school.
So,
and of course Stanford's sort of for a guy who'd never been to California and
who'd lived in miserable cold weather his whole life,
I was like,
it could have been the hundredth ranked medical school.
I was still going there.
So I have some actual stats that I pulled up.
So war zone in 1993 there was 48 murders for every hundred thousand people.
There's what?
700,000 in the,
in the city.
The next highest was in 2015 55 and in 1993 again there was 353 homicides,
homicides,
almost one a day.
And so,
you know,
I have to put this in there,
just,
you know,
because we're sitting here calling it a war zone.
So when I was in Ramadi in 2006 the one one AED,
which is the,
the ready First Brigade,
you know,
5,600 soldiers,
while we were there with them for six months,
they lost 61 guys.
So what I'm saying is now that doesn't count the enemy casualties,
but it counts the friendly casualties that are showing up at our med center.
Right.
So there,
you know,
you're talking three or 400,
well you just said one a day.
Yeah,
about one a day.
Okay.
So,
um,
so you knew how bad it was when you got weed?
Yeah,
I sort of knew it was dangerous,
but,
but I think when I decided that,
you know,
for this,
that season of my life,
you got to sacrifice everything and you'd have to go to the place where you're
going to get the best training.
And I didn't want to leave California because you know,
four years in California for the first time was,
you know,
when,
you guys know what it's like.
Yeah.
I mean,
it was like,
I don't ever want to leave this place,
but I also knew I just couldn't get that level of training on the west coast and
it was,
you know,
you basically have to go to a place like Hopkins,
Brigham and women's in Boston,
maybe wash u in St Louis was going to offer a very similar environment.
Um,
so then,
you know,
so then I ended up ranking at first they ranked me first.
So away we go,
we get lucky.
It's a match made in heaven and that's like kind of February of your senior year
and then reality sets in,
which is you've got sort of four months until you have to show up.
And that was kind of like the Oh shit moment,
right?
Like the,
I really just signed up for this.
Um,
and a good friend of mine who was two years ahead of me in medical school,
his name is Bryan Dunham.
He's now a pediatric head and neck,
ear,
nose and throat surgeon at chop in Philadelphia.
He was at Hopkins,
which was at the time the best ear,
nose and throat program in the country.
And he actually recommended,
I read this book,
the corner because,
and Brian's one of these guys who's just,
you know,
he's just,
he's like a renaissance man,
you know,
like not only is a great surgeon,
he's like a gifted artists,
you know,
his side job as medical illustration,
like you can't believe what this guy can do,
but he's introspective.
Right?
And he was,
he said,
look,
you know,
you're,
you're going to sign up to be in this war zone and you're going to be taking
care of people that it's going to be very easy to despise.
So he said,
you need to read this book to gain a sense of their perspective.
Um,
because a very,
like I said,
you know,
so,
so at the time,
I can't remember the stats.
I feel like at the time that I was there,
we averaged about 16 penetrating trauma's a day.
Now to put that in perspective,
in general surgery,
your on call every second to every fourth night.
So average about every third.
I mean it's every third night,
120 times a year.
You will spend the night in the hospital not sleeping,
waiting to take care of any trauma patient.
So if every third day and night,
you know,
16 of these people are getting shot and stabbed,
you're going to have a lot of time in the Er in the trauma bay dealing with that
and it's really easy to get jaded really quickly.
It's fun for the first month and then all of a sudden every time somebody gets
shot it's preventing you from sleeping,
which when we're sitting here all well rested sounds like a very callous thing
to say,
but all of a sudden you're sort of like,
dammit man,
like I can't eat because the trauma pager just went off again.
To this day,
I still eat shockingly fast and it drives my wife nuts,
but she doesn't understand.
I said,
I think it's just I'm a victim of,
you never know when you're going to have to stop what you're doing and that
might be your last meal.
Even I shaved quickly because the worst thing that could happen is you got
shaving cream all over and the trauma pager goes off and you've got to run down
half shaved,
you know,
you got one side of your beard down the other side,
not so stupid things like that.
So,
so that was Brian's recommendation.
So I got the book immediately devoured it,
found it to be the most depressing thing I had ever read heavy,
um,
made more depressing by the fact that they pull no punches,
no names are changed.
So every person you read about,
you were reading about it in a completely uncentered,
uncensored,
unfiltered way.
And I mean you,
you read it,
you know,
there's nothing happy about this book.
Like you just finish it and you think,
yes,
you have more empathy than you understand where,
where these folks are going to be coming from.
But it's like,
I don't,
there's,
it's not like you finished that book and go,
Oh,
here's the solution.
We need a six point plan that's going to do excellent.
It's like,
I don't know.
That's kind of why I read that one excerpt.
This is like we can't win,
which is an awful fault.
And that's what,
that's the impression the book gives you is we can't win it.
And I don't,
I that the,
the way he phrases it of being licked,
it doesn't matter how many police and whatever you do,
you're,
you're going against desire.
Well,
the,
the stat that you reiterated,
and I remember it very well from when I read this book the first time was you
couldn't take every junkie and put them away.
If you took every federal and state prison bed in Maryland,
you'd have three people for it.
If you just looked at the users,
never mind the guns,
the money and everything that comes with it.
So yeah,
that's not a solution.
Now there's a second reason that I don't think Brian knew,
cause I don't think anybody knew that that book really hit home.
Which,
um,
was it,
it,
it's,
it sounds tangential to this story,
but it becomes highly related.
And at the beginning of a
end of my third year of medical school,
I'm going to the gym one day riding my bike as I always do.
I get up,
I get to the gym,
I get off my bike,
go to lock it up.
And I was like,
my back really hurts,
like really hurt.
Not like,
oh,
it's a little stiff.
Like something feels horrible.
So I started walking down the steps to the gym and I was like,
not gonna happen today.
Like,
I mean,
I couldn't,
I couldn't do anything.
I couldn't tie my shoe.
So I just went back,
got on my bike,
rode,
rode back to my apartment,
told my roommate.
I was like,
Hey man,
I'm gonna gonna go lay a bit light down upstairs.
The next morning I woke up,
I couldn't get out of bed.
And to make a very long story short,
over the next two weeks,
I completely deteriorated.
Um,
you know,
I was at the point where I could get in and go to the hospital,
but I had to like have the nurses,
this is back in the wild west days where you could just sort of get anything you
needed at the pharmacy.
You know,
I'd get nurses or residents to inject toward all into me,
which is a really strong end.
Said,
I could only sleep if I laid in an l shape over the nurses' station.
Um,
and it just wasn't getting any better.
And then one day it pain changed immediately.
I realized in retrospect what happened,
a herniated disc had fragment had broken off.
So the pain in my back dissipated.
But now I had this,
what turned out to be a four centimeter fragments sitting on my s one nerve
root.
So now it felt like my left foot was being skinned from the bottle,
but that was constant.
So that was an unrelenting pain and it could only be sort of brought under
control if I could put my foot into a bag of ice,
cause then I could make my foot go numb and then I could take some pain
medicine.
So this went on for another week and then the dean of the medical school saw me
limping through the hospital.
I said,
what's wrong?
And I told him and he dragged me down to the Er.
We got an MRI that showed all of this.
And I was in surgery the next morning.
Uh,
this was a Sunday night.
Monday morning,
I'm in the,
or it turned into a disaster.
The Guy who operated on me operate on the wrong side.
So I woke up,
the left issue was still present,
but now I had what's called a foot drop on the right side.
So foot drop is when the nerve that holds your foot up,
which we take for granted when we walk.
But if you don't have the ability to what's called Dorsi flex,
your foot would drop.
You can't walk,
you'll end up dragging your toe when you keep tripping.
This story,
I mean,
we could spend three hours on the story because it's so idiotic.
The punchline is I eventually needed many trips back to the operating room.
This guy refused to believe there's anything wrong with me.
It took another amazing doctor,
a neurologist,
to actually intervene on my behalf.
And three months later,
I'm unable to walk.
I'm unable to do anything.
My mom actually had to fly down from Toronto to look after me.
Um,
and I'm sort of,
you know,
you go through the checklist,
right?
So,
so there's,
I don't know if you've ever heard of Elizabeth Kubler Ross.
I don't think she's alive anymore,
but she wrote a very famous book on the stages of dying and it goes through like
anger and denial and finally acceptance at the end.
Right.
And so,
you know,
bargaining like it's something that would make sense if you,
and I'm sure you've watched and you've probably watched it on really small
scales,
you know,
like in combat you might see these things over the course of compressed with a
cancer patient,
you might see this stretched out over a year.
And so I was kind of going through this on my own right,
where initially it was like,
oh my God,
what if I don't finish this rotation I'm doing right now what's called a
surgical sub internship too.
Oh,
well what if I don't graduate on time too?
What if I can't be a surgeon?
And then it was,
what if I don't walk ever again?
Um,
so somewhere along the way,
and I don't remember exactly when,
probably like a month and a half into this,
I finally caved in and started taking pain medicine.
I thought that's where the story was going.
I was like,
at some point he's going to get on the opiates.
Yep.
Been so reluctant to do so initially been so stoic,
you know,
just taking my end ceds and I'm even using Benadryl,
which is a horrible pain medication of course,
but it sedates you through some of the pain.
And so I,
you know,
I started taking Percocet and Percocet is um,
it's typically 10 milligrams of oxycodone.
Oxycodone is the fast acting version and it's stronger than say a vix or Vicodin
is Tylenol and hydrocodone immediate acting.
But hydrocodone is not as strong as oxycodone.
Percocet is stronger than Vicodin.
They both have Tylenol.
It's just the opiod is stronger.
And so,
you know,
if you take a Percocet,
which would,
we have 500 milligrams of Tylenol and 10 milligrams of Oxycodone,
you know,
I probably was taking,
start taking two,
three,
four,
five,
six of those a day,
you develop a tolerance and eventually you,
there's a longer acting version called Oxycontin,
which is just a time released version of oxycodone.
So
then you would take that twice a day.
So at my peak I was probably taking 80 milligrams of oxycontin a day,
plus another hundred and 20 milligrams of oxycodone.
I just got rid of the Tylenol all together.
You can just get straight oxycodone.
And so I'm about 200 milligrams a day of oxycodone equivalent.
And again,
if you know,
if I took that today,
I would just die because you just stop breathing.
But at the time,
you know,
you build up this tolerance.
But it also,
there was this point where I realized that I wasn't just taking it for the
physical pain.
Right.
And I think this is the single most important insight I had that when coupled
with reading that book six months later was the,
I think the single most important realization I ever had with respect to,
to this problem,
which was at some point it was,
I was just so depressed that I couldn't walk and I was so worried that I'd never
be able to do anything again.
That at least the drug gave me a high.
That took me away from that.
And so then it got to the point where I was just taking that drug all the time
and I just stopped engaging,
like wasn't engaged with anyone,
anything.
Um,
and then I sort of had this realization that that was happening and I was like,
I,
I want to stop.
So at the time I was dating this girl,
she was an anesthesiology residents.
She was a few years older than me,
re just the coolest,
coolest person.
And I'd said to her,
she was kind of the only one that knew what was going on because at the time,
even the doctors who are prescribing this,
like this just wasn't on people's radar as a problem back then.
I think today people would be like,
homeboy,
he's got 200 milligrams of Oxycontin a day.
That's probably not good.
But at the time it was just like,
it was like tic tacs.
That's right.
So that would legitimately kill it.
Like if I took 200 milligrams,
would that,
that would really Jackson went up,
I would think.
I think if I took 200 today,
I would stop breathing.
Yeah.
Cause that's how opiates kill you.
They repress,
they inhibit respiratory drive.
That's what,
whenever,
whenever someone overdoses on heroin,
they just stopped breathing.
Um,
so yeah,
I think 200 would,
I don't know.
We'd have to,
I'd have to look at the farm right after.
Um,
she,
she said,
you can't just stop right?
You,
the withdrawal is so painful that you have to taper off.
You have to probably go on Methadone and then you'd have to start some pretty
potent antidepressants like Maoi or Tca.
So you have to go on a drug like nor triptolene,
which is in and of itself kind of a crazy thing.
And I was like,
yeah,
but I think I'm just going to stop cold Turkey now,
unlike alcohol.
So if you took an alcoholic,
you know,
you took someone who is drinking 20 alcohol,
alcoholic beverages a day and they've been doing that forever and you stop them,
they will die.
They will get something called Delirium tremens and they will die a horrible
cardiac death.
They will break into a arrhythmias.
They will die.
So
when we had alcoholics in the hospital,
and let's say we had to operate on somebody who happened to be an alcoholic,
we would actually just put them on an ethanol eat.
We weren't even trying to detox them.
We just want to make sure they didn't die and go into these delirium tremens
but,
but heroin and opiod is not like that.
It is not physiologically lethal to stop cold Turkey.
It's just unbearable.
And so I was like,
I'm going to do it.
So against her better judgement,
I just stopped one day and she could not have been more.
Right.
It was the darkest,
I mean,
I can laugh about it now.
It was the darkest month of my life.
It was a month.
Oh,
at least.
I mean it was,
I would just sit on a park bench for the whole afternoon,
like complete flat affect.
But it's all mental.
It's not a physical thing.
No,
there's physical stuff.
Yeah.
Going on.
I mean,
but,
but no,
it's,
yeah,
you're,
you know,
you,
you sort of like,
you know,
opiates make you itch like crazy.
You get constipated.
So there's like a reversal of a whole bunch of physical stuff.
But the biggest thing is the craving and the depression.
Um,
and so the depression of coming off this thing was brutal.
in many ways.
And I don't tell that story to say,
well look at how special I am that I detox.
That's not the point at all.
I had two things going for me that virtually no junkie has going for them.
Right?
The first is I didn't have a network of people around me that were doing the
same thing.
So I was sort of the only guy doing it.
So for me to go and be around my friends was to be around people who weren't
doing this.
We always used to joke that if you really want to kick a heroin habit,
you have to get a whole bunch of new friends like you.
You don't get to decide you're not doing heroin and then go back and hang with
your friends that are doing hair when you need to watch trainspotting to learn
that.
The second thing,
and perhaps the more important thing is I finally did connect with a doctor who
was able to put me on the right path.
So I,
I had ended up going back to the operating room probably half a dozen times over
the course of the year to have all these problems corrected and then I found
something else to fix it on,
which was physical therapy.
So I started to,
you know,
even though it didn't seem like exercise,
it wouldn't seem like exercise today.
At the time it was the first activity I was able to do.
And so,
you know,
within six months I could like walk like a reasonable distance again.
And so I would be spending three hours a day at physical therapy just doing like
the most trivial exercises.
But basically the root cause of my depression was getting better.
So that's really the only reason I think I was able to kind of detox off this
stuff.
Whereas I think for many people,
a,
it's not clear what the root causes or B,
it's not getting better if it is clear.
And so that's why I think it's really,
it's a,
it's a brutal addiction.
And it seems like also you had a future,
right?
You had a life,
you are in medical school,
you're going to,
you know,
you're going to ask a lot of these people that are drug addicts,
what do they,
they have no life that they're looking forward.
They're just looking forward to nothing.
And so in February of that senior year,
when I had to submit my rank list,
I think we match in March,
I misspoke earlier.
I was still not functional perfectly.
Like there was no way in February of 2001 that I could have withstood a surgical
residency,
but I had to make a decision at that point,
which was,
will I be ready on July 1st and if I won't be,
I should not submit my rank.
I should defer a year,
sit out a year in medical school,
whatever.
And I remember that was the hardest decision I had to make and I just gambled.
I was like,
you know what,
I'm going to be ready and I'm going to make it happen no matter what.
And so I submitted matched and then in addition to now reading the corner to
prepare for Baltimore and reflecting on my own sort of struggled with addiction,
which was completely fresh in my mind.
I'm also like rehabbing,
like it's my day job and going through like as an eye.
Most people take the last quarter in med school off,
but I didn't have the ability to do that now because I had the,
I had to go straight through till graduation day because I'd missed so much time
during my injury.
Um,
so when I showed up in Baltimore a couple of days before July 1st I mean it
still wasn't crystal clear to me that I could go,
you know,
two days without sleeping,
standing in Orr for eight hours at a time.
All those sorts of things.
Yeah,
no,
that's one of the things,
the sleep deprivation,
cause people always,
obviously I take a lot of flack because I don't sleep a lot and,
and the sleep deprivation.
So what did that low,
what's that like when you're going through residency and you're just saying,
I mean there's days where you're going 24,
48 hours,
no sleep.
And how'd that affect you?
What did you think of that?
What do you think?
Looking back at it,
w w what's your opinion of it now?
Well,
you know,
when I decided that I was going to go into surgery,
I mean I,
I always,
I'm pretty,
uh,
insecure in general.
Most people don't necessarily appreciate that on the outside,
but always thinking,
I don't know if I've got what it takes here,
how do I figure it out?
And so my,
my whole emo in life is test the system hard.
So when I was in medical school still deciding this,
I figured,
well,
every Thursday night I'm going to pull an all nighter in my room,
standing up,
not allow myself to eat,
sleep,
drink,
pee,
do anything.
And I'm a stand at my desk for eight hours and practice suturing,
you know,
sort of try to mimic what it would be like to be in an operating room all night,
not being able to go pee and not being able to drink,
not going to do this thing.
And so I had a little bit of confidence,
you know,
I figured,
okay,
I can do this.
Like I can pull an all nighter once a week.
That's,
you know,
not that that's a good thing to do,
but it was like kind of a confidence thing.
Right.
So then you show up,
but there's no preparing you for what you're in store for.
Now I got to point out this is not the way it is anymore.
So in 2000,
I want to say like four,
um,
like labor laws came in exactly the,
a whole bunch of laws came in that we could spend hours talking about how it
turns out the laws haven't,
they haven't fixed the underlying root problem,
but nevertheless,
a whole bunch of work requirement hours stuff got fixed.
Right.
So you couldn't work more than 80 hours in a week or 88,
depending on if your program had an exemption and you couldn't work more than 24
hours consecutively and stuff like that.
But by the time those laws really kicked in,
I was already gone.
And,
and so I don't really know what it's like today,
but I would imagine it's,
um,
it's less demanding from a sleep deprivation standpoint.
But at the time there were no such rules and you were at the sort of every
second,
every third or every fourth night call.
But then your post call day you would still work.
So our mutual friend,
Kirk Parsley,
which of course is how we met,
this is one of his favorite stories about me because he loves this story because
it's so crazy.
So this is July of 2001.
So I am one month into being a doc,
right?
And I'm on an every third night call rotation at this hospital called Bayview,
which is about five miles from what we call the mothership,
which is Hopkins.
And it's out in like East Baltimore.
It's in a real crappy part of town.
Not that there's,
isn't really,
I mean,
I hate saying this,
but I don't,
they're not that many good parts of town,
at least back then in Baltimore.
Um,
and uh,
so I'm a,
so I show up on a Monday at five o'clock in the morning.
So I slept in my own bed Sunday night.
So Monday morning I show up at five to round,
we do our whole thing and that night I'm supposed to go home.
So that's my off,
cause you called your swing day,
you show up at five,
you'll be home by 7:00 PM that night.
If all goes well.
So you worked your,
you know,
14 hours and then you sleep in your own bed and then you get to come back the
next day and then you're going to be on call.
So at the,
so we're rounding that afternoon.
So,
and the,
uh,
the,
the s one of the senior resident says,
Hey,
so and so didn't show up for their shift in the Er.
The Er always staffs one surgical resident fulltime and this guy just didn't
show up.
And she's like,
and it's a 7:00 PM to 7:00 AM shift,
can you cover it?
And you know,
this would be like if you ask the most junior guy you know to do something like
he,
he'd be kicking his own ass to say yes.
Like he couldn't wait to do that.
Right.
So I was like,
hell yes,
I will do that.
So then I go down to the Er and I work all night,
seven to seven and then the next morning is now my on call day.
So now I'm 7:00 AM cranking away until that night.
And then I'm up all night on call.
So,
and then it's now Wednesday and it's my post call day and I'm there till
five or 6:00 PM so I've basically been up from about 4:00 AM Monday and it's now
five or 6:00 PM Wednesday
and I get in my car to drive home and I have to make it,
I have to go down this miserable street called Eastern Avenue to hit the 83 to
drive up to my place.
And I'm driving along eastern avenue,
which is like red light after red light after red light or stop sign or
whatever.
And every time I'm at a stoplight,
I fall asleep,
my foot pops off the clutch and I stall.
Like I am so tired,
I can't even,
you know,
handle like the gradual,
easing off the clutch and the gas just to move up and up and up.
I can't do it.
So finally,
in one moment of lucid clarity,
I'm like,
you can't get on the freeway,
you're going to die.
So I was like,
what's the solution?
I was like,
you gotta get over and take a nap.
So I pull over my car on the side of eastern avenue right in front of this park
called Patterson Park,
which at the time,
I don't think I fully understood that that was an open air drug traffic market.
So I got up,
but here's the best part of,
sorry,
the logical thing to do would have been just in,
stayed in the car and take a nap.
But I was like,
yeah,
I haven't seen the sunlight in like days.
And it's,
the sun is still out.
Like I'm going to go nap in the park.
So I get out of the park,
I'm in green scrubs that are covered in bloodstains cause I was too dumb to not
change.
I go lay down in the park,
I take my page or off and I clip it to my neck and I set the alarm to let go off
in one hour,
you know,
so at like 7:00 PM it'll wake me up and I'll feel perfectly rested and I'll be
able to drive home.
So I laid down and middle of Patterson Park and the next thing I know I wake up,
it's like one in the morning,
two in the morning,
there's needles everywhere there is,
I have like a bite on my arm that looked like they're from rats cause they're
like nothing I've ever seen before.
Like these bites all over me and I'm just thinking to myself like,
how did I not get killed here?
Like the only thing that prevented me from dying was how ridiculous the site
was.
You know,
if something's so strange,
like nothing,
you know,
so I was like,
God damn it man.
So I get back in my car and drove home and when I tell Parsi that story,
he loves it because he's like,
that's the classic example of how complete deprivation of sleep impairs your
judgment.
Um,
so you know,
there were a couple stories in residency where I had to do like those three
night back to back to backs.
Another time it happened,
I remember was an okay.
Do you feel like though,
okay,
driving a car is kind of boring stop lights,
but when you're really tired,
but then all of a sudden something happens like boom.
I feel like when that happens,
I feel I can lock on it.
There's almost no amount of sleep deprivation that will stop me from functioning
and getting something done that's important all on task on time.
Absolutely.
Is that true?
Does that true?
No,
I think,
I think an adrenaline rush in the can provide any amount of clarity and focus
that's necessary.
The problem is very few things are life or death that way.
Now in your world,
there were plenty of things,
but in my world not,
and this is the extra.
So sure.
I was going to tell it was
in a pretty my third year,
uh,
I think it was my third year.
Um,
I was same,
same sort of deal.
I ended up covering for somebody and then covering for two people in two
consecutive nights.
And then it was my turn.
So that was like three straight nights of not sleeping and it's the middle of
the night.
And this guy comes in the Er who's,
you know,
got a really diseased gallbladder.
And in retrospect it should've never come out that night.
But a lot of times the dirty little secret is surgeons want to operate at night
cause they can get better.
Oh our time electively as opposed to waiting the next day if it's not emergent.
So sure enough,
we're in the middle of the operating room doing a laparoscopic gallbladder
removal at two in the morning when we don't really need to be there two in the
morning.
We could've slept and done it the next day.
Um,
and sure enough,
so,
so in a lab in removing the gallbladder is a two surgeon procedure.
So there's the main surgeon,
which because we're a teaching hospital,
I'm the main surgeon,
I'm actually doing the operation and then there's the attending who's holding
the camera and retracting for me.
So I'm like,
I'm doing this.
And yeah,
that's a stimulating activity.
But of course I've done a hundred of them so it's not that stimulating.
Well,
I can't stay awake.
And I finally somehow managed to fall asleep on this patient,
like I face plant into patient.
Wow.
Luckily it was laparoscopic so I didn't contaminate the surgical,
but so
even something as stimulating as surgery because it would look if the guy's
aorta was bleeding,
I'm sure I would have.
Yeah,
exactly.
But now you're doing this full of copper gallbladders no big thing.
Yeah.
It wasn't stimulating enough to overcome three days of sleep debt.
Did you do?
Did you figured out any tricks?
Any,
you know,
for instance,
I can tell when I was going through seal training and even my,
my whole career and even to this day,
I take these,
I take a little power naps.
If I'm feeling that tired,
I elevate my feet and I sleep for like six to eight minutes and it totally
recharges me.
Did you,
do you take power naps?
Okay.
No.
Aside from your power nap parking,
it lasted seven hours and almost guys you killed.
I did
power nap in my car again,
same thing.
I was like,
there's like eight o'clock at night.
I got to the pool.
I had a rule,
which was after you left the hospital,
you never went home because I knew if I went home I wasn't going to leave.
So I would always go from the hospital to the gym or the pool or whatever I was
doing.
And on this particular night I get there,
it's eight o'clock at night.
I am so tired.
I'm nauseous.
Like the thought of that.
You didn't want to go home just because you knew you'd go to sleep?
I fall asleep,
I want to go to sleep because you've been awake for three days.
Why didn't you warn off?
Why don't,
why don't,
why don't you want to go and fall asleep?
The funny,
a good friend of mine who again,
a couple of years ahead of me,
gave me interesting advice,
whether it was right or wrong,
I don't know.
He said,
look,
you're going to be tired no matter what in residency.
Don't stop all the other things in your life because you'll still be tired.
Now.
I don't know that that was the right advice,
but I took it to heart and in my view was I'm going to continue to work out
every day.
I'm not on call,
I'm gonna,
you know,
do all the stuff I want to do.
And unfortunately sleep always took the brunt of it.
So yeah,
so it would be to the pool.
And so same thing I got there,
but on this particular night I was so tired.
I was so nauseous.
Like I couldn't suppress the desire to vomit.
And I was like,
I'm not gonna.
I can't,
if I puke in the pool,
they'll kick me out.
I won't get to soon as it's not going to be worth it.
So I was like,
just sit here for like 30 minutes and take a quick nap.
So same thing.
Took the page you're out,
which normally could wake me up,
clip it here.
And it was freezing because it was like the winter.
So I left.
No,
it wasn't cold,
but I remember wanting to leave the radio on.
I like a dumb ass.
So the car is off.
So alternators off radios on what?
You know how the story ends?
I wake up at two in the morning,
battery's dead.
I'm in the middle of the parking lot.
I can't,
you know,
I had to call my girlfriend,
get jumper cables to get me out.
That's a girlfriend went on to become my wife,
by the way.
Um,
so short answer,
no,
I didn't have a great strategy.
I did have a friend who,
and I never tried this,
but he told me he would put coffee grounds in his eyelids.
Apparently it hurts so much that you couldn't close your eyes.
Okay.
That's what I mean,
I would not that,
but I've told people this all the time to,
you know,
do,
do a little bit of physical exercise.
If you're super tired,
that definitely picks you back up.
There's gotta be some reality or some scientific reason for that happening is
that's another thing you can do.
But um,
so you were so okay,
we know it's socks.
You're not sleeping and you're dealing with these patients.
And how do you start to detach from this reality that's around you so you're not
getting,
you know,
cause you,
you,
you said already you like to kind of the emotional involvement with people.
But then at the same time you said it didn't take long before you despise these
patients that are coming in because they're interrupting your sleep and
bothering you.
That's gotta be a crazy balance to try and strike as a human being.
I mean,
human beings are not meant to be dealing with 16 puncture wounds a day.
That's,
that's not right.
So what,
what happens in your brain?
What happened in your mind?
What did you notice about your mentality and this whole business as time went
on?
Well,
what I noticed,
so again,
not everybody becomes jaded,
but most people do.
And where,
where my sense of jaded developed was actually towards,
you know,
the patients with diabetes,
the patients who had complications from being overweight.
Like when those people would show up with,
you know,
the abscess in their foot in the middle of the night,
that needed to be debris.
Did those people,
I would get,
again,
pretty pissed at amazingly the,
that what we,
you know,
these,
these folks,
like I kind of always maintained a soft spot in my heart for them.
And interestingly,
you know,
it's,
it's easy once they die.
Yeah.
So,
so what happens is,
let's say a guy comes in,
you guy's been shot.
Um,
you know,
generally people who are dead in the field don't make it in.
So,
so,
but,
but sometimes there's this gray zone where,
you know,
someone comes in who's basically dead,
but because they had a little bit of a pulse on the way in the door,
like,
we're gonna do everything we can.
But a lot of times when those patients die,
like the room has to be turned over really quickly,
which means someone's got to come in and take the body,
put it in a body bag,
gather everything.
Cause usually these are criminal investigation.
So the police are there,
the housekeeping staff has to come in and mop all the blood off the floor
because depending on where the gunshot wound was,
like gunshot wound to the head,
for example,
tons of blood.
Um,
because the heads of confined space,
um,
and in that moment it's really easy to just immediately walk out the door.
But I find myself,
you know,
I'd,
I'd sometimes like flip through their wallets.
Right.
And you know,
invariably you'd see something like you'd see a picture of a little kid.
So you see this guy who's huge,
who's just been killed,
he's probably 25 and you'd see like this six year old girl in his wallet and
you,
you know,
you'd start to sort of wonder what the narrative is,
right?
Like is that his daughter?
Probably.
Did he know her?
Did she know him?
Maybe not.
Like,
you just don't know.
And all of a sudden that that's,
that's,
that's a sort of humanizes these,
these guys.
And again,
I think because of my own understanding of what they were dealing with because
of those 16 penetrating traumas,
15 had to be drug involved in one way or another.
Um,
and so everybody who were taken care of for the most part was some part of the
cycle that's being described in the corner.
Now occasionally it wouldn't be,
I mean one of the examples that stands out that was,
I would say sort of like the top five saddest things I ever saw in residency was
July 1st,
2002 I just happen to remember that day.
And this girl on her 16th birthday came in and she was just,
she was just hit by a stray bullet in her neighborhood.
It was her 60th birthday stray bullet from,
you know,
unrelated gang violence.
Hit her in the head.
And you know,
she's an example of someone who came in basically dead.
But in situations like that,
like you'll,
you know,
I'm sure you can relate to this.
You're just going to do something that's so beyond heroic.
You want to do anything and everything to try to save her.
And of course we couldn't.
So,
you know,
those examples are kind of rare,
but the majority of the Times it's,
you know,
executions for people who stole money.
Um,
that's,
those,
those would be hard to see.
Right?
Because you see these girls,
you know,
this is like this is a deadly game.
No.
And even the,
even the girl,
the 16 year old girl,
she's part of the cycle too because that's just a stray bullet.
That's right.
She's in a,
she's in a lousy neighborhood.
You can almost guarantee that,
you know,
if she's living in where she's living to get hit by a stray bullet,
like,
you know,
yeah.
She wasn't living in,
you know,
Roland Park.
And when,
once you,
did you,
would you ever see any family would have any family ever come in?
Yeah.
So there's two types of things going on,
right?
So,
so the,
the biggest problem we would have would be real gang on gang stuff because it
became sort of a feed forward loop.
Right?
So if one guy came in and he was killed,
you immediately knew the flood gates were going to open because there's going to
be retaliation that night.
I don't remember.
The police were pretty good about trying to make sure that like when someone
came in and who was killed,
like if you weren't immediate family,
you were not allowed there.
Um,
and they also tried to create a little bit of a delay and letting that
information out.
Again,
maybe that wasn't the,
the,
the most considerate thing to do,
but their view was trying to let the violence dissipate.
Um,
yeah,
the family stuff's hard.
I mean,
the hardest family interaction I ever had was with,
uh,
with,
actually a blunt trauma and it wasn't involving drugs at all.
Right.
This was,
uh,
this was a,
um,
a boy.
He was 15 years old.
He and his brother,
his older brother who was probably 18,
had picked him up after school.
They were driving home and they were,
they had the right away and a guy ran a red light and t-boned them on the
passenger side.
And this,
the 15 year old boy,
both of them came in as separate traumas,
but the older boy came in as an adult trauma.
So he went to the adult side.
I happened to be on pediatric surgery,
like I was the senior resident on pediatric surgery that month.
So I ran a pediatric trauma,
which is where the 15 year old came in.
And that turned out the older,
the driving son was fine.
He didn't have a scratch on his body,
but this kid came in basically dead on arrival though it wasn't clear why,
but his pupils were blown.
Um,
you know,
little bit of a pulse.
We did,
you know,
probably 30 minutes of everything imaginable before accepting the reality that
he shared his aorta.
So if a,
a high enough force can actually share the aorta and it dissects and you
basically bleed to death inside the wall of the aorta.
And that's why he died.
And that was another example of how everybody just sort of scatters after that.
But you know,
his mom is in a waiting room wondering where her boys are,
who,
you know,
could have been in a fender bender for all she knows.
So
those were,
I mean,
unquestionably the most difficult discussions ever because trauma is the one
area where
there's complete surprise.
Like,
you know,
it's tragic when somebody dies from cancer.
It's even tragic when somebody dies during an elective surgical operation,
which happens unfortunately from time to time.
But at least there you have some heads up that something dangerous is going on.
But this kid like,
you know,
said goodbye to his mum that day,
went to school and never came and now she
hears,
oh,
he's in a car accident and she's in the hospital.
Never imagining that he could be dead.
And then you have to be the guy that goes in and say,
you know,
I'm really sorry to tell you this,
but your son is dead.
You know,
there's actually a really interesting article written in the New York Times on
this exact topic,
um,
by,
uh,
so it's kind of interesting story.
So my mentor in medical school to this day,
one of the closest mentors I've ever had is a guy by the name of Steve
Rosenberg.
So Steve Rosenberg is the chief of surgery at the National Cancer Institute and
he's kind of one of the luminaries in immunotherapy.
So I did my postdoc with him at the Nih and uh,
I actually spent time there in medical school and actually he just called me
yesterday out of the blue.
We ended up having a great catch up for 30 minutes.
His daughter,
his three daughters,
his youngest daughter is Naomi Rosenberg,
who's,
uh,
a resident at and I think she's an emergency room doc at Penn,
which is also in a war zone in Philly.
And she wrote a great piece on this,
which maybe we could link to in the notes or something.
Um,
it's probably like the last three months about the difficulty of having to
communicate to families when tragedies like this happen,
which of course,
you know,
she would see a lot of as well in Philly.
And then that happens.
So you do everything you can to save this kid's life.
And then you walk in,
you face the mother,
you drop the most devastating possible imaginable news on her,
and you got to go back to work.
I mean,
right.
don't you then have to,
isn't it?
Don't you have to go work again now that,
that night in particular,
that was,
um,
I remember that day pretty well.
That was April of 2003,
um,
when that boy died.
And,
um,
but at the time,
you know,
by the time we had declared time of death and I had gone to talk to his mom,
it was probably like 10 o'clock at night,
you know,
I probably spent an hour with her.
And of course it's disruptive because you're in there and your pager is going
off.
I've got the Er calling me about this kid and I've got the ICU calling me about
this and you know,
um,
and she's,
you know,
I mean,
like I,
I,
God,
I sure hope I never have to know what she went through because I can't,
can't really imagine.
Right.
I mean,
she's hysterical at a level that you just like a movie doesn't do justice to
that.
Like you don't see that level of hysteria normally.
Um,
and I,
I that that was certainly like one of kind of the three or four that really
upset me the most.
I mean,
I,
I had a real hard time getting,
I think I got lucky that night.
I think that at night ended up being a pretty calm night.
I remember I got to probably spend some time just alone in a call room that
evening.
You know?
And,
and for me that was a,
so the,
this is the awful thing is we tend to project what's going on in our own life,
into any situation.
I mean,
I,
I think I realized that pretty early.
And so I think in the case of that particular trauma I saw in that boy,
my brother,
my younger brother.
And so I,
so I was dealing with two things in that moment.
One was,
um,
meaning from my own and not,
not,
not the immediate issue,
which is this boy died.
One is I'm imagining now like this could have been me and my brother in high
school like this.
This could have been us.
And how,
how your life changes after that.
Like I thought his brother's life is never going to be the same.
Um,
the second was,
this was already after I had decided to leave medicine altogether.
Um,
which was in June of 2006 and this,
this trauma,
it was like April of 2006 so I decided in March of that year that I was just
going to finish that year and then leave.
So,
so the other thing that was sort of,
that I was struggling with,
which probably makes us a little heavier than it needed to be,
was as painful as this is,
it's a privilege to be this person.
It's a privilege to be the guy who gets to try to save a life.
And even when you fail that interaction you're going to have with that family,
which I think is something they only wrote about in that piece.
It's so important.
It seems trivial to us because you have that interaction over and over and over
again.
But to that family,
it's so important that will be with them forever.
And I think I felt that,
I felt that that was a privilege.
And so I think I realized like,
I'll never do this again.
I'll never again have that privilege to,
even if I fail to,
to try to,
you know,
sort of say to somebody to actually then be able to comfort that family.
And that sounds really weird and it's a very morose sort of thought to have.
But all of those things,
I think in that particular example,
um,
you know,
made for a really difficult,
uh,
set of,
you know,
days and weeks that followed.
I went to his funeral,
his first patient I ever went to a funeral of a first trauma patient,
certainly went to the funerals of patients.
You've got to know through,
you know,
people who were dying of cancer and stuff,
but,
you know,
trauma patient,
like you just wouldn't think to go to someone's funeral that you'd never known
because like,
I'd never known that boy.
Right.
Um,
I stayed in touch with his mom for a few years and not surprisingly,
their life just completely fell apart.
You know?
Does it make it that much worse that you got this?
You juxtapose the,
the kind of this normal kid,
right?
Who dies this random accident and then at the same time every night you're,
you've got people that are killing each other
and you're dealing with and you're seeing the results of that and you can't do
anything about it.
How does it,
does that also play into your,
your thoughts about,
hey,
I'm here trying to save these people's lives and they're out there killing each
other for over nothing over the street corner over this,
over that.
Did you go down that road?
Mentally,
I'm
not there.
I'll tell you
the one time I felt really ethically,
maybe ethnically is too strong a word,
but just to be blunt,
I mean,
the one time I was really pissed off that I was trying to save somebody's life
was a guy that came in who killed his wife,
killed his daughter,
and then put the gun in his under his Chin and pulled the trigger and mist.
So he basically blew off the side of his face and was still alive.
His brain was completely intact.
This guy was going to survive after 23 you know,
face operations,
and you know,
I'm taking care of this guy in the ICU and I'm kind of pissed off about it
actually,
right?
And maybe I shouldn't be right?
Who am I to judge this guy?
But I'm like,
you know,
you killed your wife,
you killed your kid and you wanted to die.
Why the hell am I putting anything into you?
Now,
of course,
that is a slippery slope because in medicine we're never supposed to play that
role,
right?
We're never,
we never play God,
right?
People,
you know,
some doctors want to act like they're playing God,
but we never played God.
We're just there to do a job.
And on that day I remember thinking,
I don't want to do this job.
I don't want to,
I don't want to take care of this guy or I want this guy to die.
Actually.
How do they,
how do they,
how do they address that when you're going to medical school,
that whole idea they've got a covered on,
or is it just so underlying that the underlying theme of everything you do that
by the time you get done it's there?
Well,
that's a,
that's a really good question.
I don't know.
Are there ethic ethics classes in medical school that teach you that?
I am sure who are there.
Are I the fact that I can't tell you one thing about an ethics class I took
tells you it,
that whatever ethics you have are going to be independent of whatever class
you're taking.
And who knows?
You know,
today,
you know,
these pendulums swing from one end to the other for all I know,
half the curriculum could be ethics today.
I don't know.
But,
but the short answer is I think,
you know,
it's,
it's sort of internal and the reality of it is,
you know,
if you're in a good program and the one thing I'll say,
I mean,
as much as Hopkins was a brutal place to exist,
the camaraderie there was unbelievable.
I mean,
you know,
the nickname for the residents was the Halstead marines,
right?
Which again,
it doesn't do justice to real marines,
but that was sort of the camaraderie,
right?
It was like you would do anything for your rest,
you know,
that's why you'd always volunteer to stay up three nights to help somebody else
out.
And so,
you know,
I hadn't really great friends there.
And in fact to this day,
like some of my closest friends,
people that I'm in touch with almost every day,
we're were guys I went through that experience with.
And you could talk about those things with each other,
right?
I mean,
you know,
it was,
it was okay to say like,
I really wished this mother fucker would die because he's taking up a bed,
he's costing the state 1 million bucks and I hate him.
Um,
and I think somehow being able to talk about
that,
I think makes it a little bit easier.
Right?
Well,
absolutely.
I mean,
in any,
that's what happens in the military.
You get guys that go through tough situations,
tough battles,
and they are,
they become closer going through it.
And part of the thing that brings them closer together.
So you're talking about what's going on as it's happening and after it happens.
What did you,
so
a lot of times in this,
this podcast,
I say that this podcast,
yeah,
we talk about war and we talk about leadership and we talk about history,
but I find that the actual root of what the podcast becomes about is,
is really about human nature and what people,
what human beings are like.
Was there,
I'll give you both sides of this question.
Did you learn anything about people,
about human nature there?
That was surprisingly positive.
And before you answer that one,
did you learn anything about human nature while you were there?
That was surprisingly negative.
So,
so I'll give you one thing that I learned that I don't know that I would call
positive or negative,
but it was an observation that in retrospect seems obvious but it never would
have.
I never would thought of it before.
And to this day it still serves me well to understand it.
So the opposite,
the fruit does,
the first observation is that,
um,
when you look at a significant illness,
like a,
a,
a completely disruptive insult,
you know,
cancer,
you have pancreatic cancer,
which means you're going to die and you're going to die soon.
Um,
there are two types of families that come into that situation.
So families that show up already fractured,
get blown apart,
fractures that families that show up already tight become the tightest of any
family.
The same would be true when you see,
you know,
a kid that comes in,
a burn victim,
right?
As kid that gets burned badly on the 4th of July and this kid's going to spend
the next two months in the hospital.
Um,
you know,
a couple that comes in with tension already in their marriage.
They get splintered,
wide open.
If they came in and everything was fine,
they're going to be there for each other,
they're going to be tighter.
So,
so that was an observation that I just saw over and over and over again.
And I sought in probably even more,
um,
vivid color when I was at the Nih because the two years I was there,
you know,
I was mostly doing research,
but you still had clinical responsibilities and so you're,
you're basically seeing patients who are coming to receive experimental therapy
for cancer.
So these are patients who were all,
you know,
otherwise going to die within six months and most of them will still go on to
die.
Obviously the,
a subset of them we can help,
but you're seeing over and over again.
So that was the first observation.
And then the second was that there were just a couple of residents who,
um,
I couldn't believe how amazing they could be,
how they could never sort of do the wrong thing.
So,
so there,
there were two residents in particular.
One really,
he was,
he,
his name is Chris Sonne and day he is now a,
uh,
he's a transplant surgeon at the University of Michigan.
Amazing guy.
And so Chris was two years ahead of me and I mean,
he was like that guy that I would have done anything for.
And I remember when I was leaving thinking to myself,
you know,
I'm really glad I'm leaving because if I stayed,
I'd know I could never be as good as Chris like that.
Like,
how can someone be this good?
And I don't mean like he can so this good and cut that out.
I don't mean even medically and human,
just as exactly as a human being.
He is on a level I can't get to.
And you know,
I don't know anybody else who can get there either,
but the fact that I can't get there is a little upsetting to me.
Um,
and I'm glad I don't have to spend the rest of my life chasing him,
which of course Chris would never think of it that way because that's the nature
of being that guy as you is just completely humble,
modest,
unassuming guy who just happens to be a god.
You know,
it's,
uh,
going back to the first point that you mentioned,
and it's something that I've heard people talk about as well,
my buddy's talk about is,
you know,
the,
the whole idea of post traumatic stress and all that and,
and what war does to people,
and one thing that I happened to agree with is pretty similar to what you're
saying and that is going into the war,
right?
If the person is got a good stable mindset and a good attitude and is a positive
person and they're going to come out of it with all those good positive things
amplified,
they're going to be more positive.
They're going to be stronger,
they're going to be mentally tougher.
It's the people that go into it that are already somehow fractured.
Those fractures are going to get worse through the trauma of combat.
Again,
um,
this is a broad generalization and there's definitely great guys that see things
or do things that they,
that it hurts them and it takes them a while to get through it.
But there's also some guys that you go,
you know,
that guy was messed up when we showed up and now he's worse and it,
and it's that pressure that opens up those fractures even wider.
And it's interesting that you got this,
you saw that with family structures as well.
And I could completely see how that happens.
And that happens,
right?
That happens in it.
You don't even need trauma to make that happen.
I mean,
when you get the financial trauma on a family,
if they're not tight,
that'll,
that'll make him blow up.
Whereas if they're tight,
you don't going through some financial problems,
they'll get,
they'll buckle down,
they'll save money together,
they'll skip the movies,
they'll start,
you know,
they'll enjoy cooking ramen noodles together so that trauma can,
can expose those fractures.
That's why it's important to try and create the most solid foundation you can
with your family and with your own mind.
So that when these traumas hit,
you don't get fractures screen for that.
They try to,
but um,
you'll like this story.
So we had to take a psychological screening.
This isn't the 90,
so it wasn't like we were super advanced on any of this stuff.
And I'm going,
you know,
when I was going through bootcamp,
they gave us a psychological screening for,
for our attempt to go to,
to seal training.
And so they asked a bunch of questions and it was complete the sentence
questions.
And so it would,
it was really obvious what would,
what would flag you and for,
and,
and so I made every answer,
uh,
cause we,
I was in boot camp and the food sucked.
And so every answer that I gave was just all about food.
So for instance,
they'd,
they'd say,
complete this sentence.
I hate when my mother,
right.
So it's pretty easy to,
to say,
you know,
I hate when my mother shuns me in front of my sisters and I want to kill her.
No,
no,
no.
All my answers were like,
you know,
I hate when my mother overcooks the steak and doesn't put enough pepper on it.
You know,
just like every answer I gave was about food,
but it was really easy.
My point is that it was really obvious if you were not a complete,
even if you were,
if you,
in fact,
if you were a psychopath,
you would very easily say,
answer all the questions correctly and get through it.
And there's been plenty of guys that made it through seal training that,
you know,
there's,
there's some bad criminals,
there's a,
there's been a couple really heinous crimes committed by guys that were seals
and just,
just if they made it through,
they got screened.
So yeah,
they,
they had a screening,
but I wouldn't say it's the most effective.
They've gotten better now,
you know,
in some of those guys that committed horrible crimes,
it,
you know,
kind of inspired the seal teams to step up that screening process as much as
possible to make sure that we're not letting guys through that or that are
deranged some way that are going to do something horrible like that.
Um,
you kind of already talked about these,
but is there any other thing that,
that you learned about yourself
in that situation and,
and you,
I didn't really know too much about the,
uh,
where you went afterwards that the NIH,
if you want to go into that a little bit,
but what did you learn about yourself through this whole process?
Obviously you learned something because at some point you decided,
you know what,
I don't want to,
I don't want to do this.
Yeah.
I mean that's,
those are,
those are some of the most interesting years of my life and I,
I'm pretty glad that I didn't have my first kid til I was 35 which on the one
hand you,
you sort of think,
well,
God,
I'm so old,
you know,
like,
I'm not going to be,
I'm not going be like the 50
year old grandfather.
Right.
Um,
but on the other hand,
I think it's a really good thing because when I think about what was going on in
my mid to late twenties,
you know,
the,
the sort of really difficult decisions I had to make.
I mean,
leaving medicine after being in it for 10 years was a really difficult decision,
especially to go and do something that had nothing to do with medicine.
I mean,
when I left,
I joined a consulting firm,
Mckinsey and Company,
and I did credit risk modeling.
Like I didn't have a thing.
The fact that I was a doctor was like a liability.
There was no,
like,
it was like starting all over again in life.
Um,
so to get to that point,
yeah,
I had to go through a whole bunch of stuff.
So I think,
I mean,
I don't know,
I wouldn't even know where to begin.
I mean,
I think one thing I learned was,
so this fellow that I alluded to earlier,
Steve Rosenberg,
who is again to this day,
probably one of the most important mentors in my life outside of family members,
um,
just an amazing human being,
right?
So just kind of on another level,
and I remember even asking him after being in his lab for two years,
because remember we had a couple of people in the lab who I just didn't think
were that good.
They really bugged me.
Their existence bothered me.
And I,
and I finally,
after being in the lab for two years,
worked up the courage to ask him like,
how he,
because he's like this guy who's going to win a Nobel prize.
Like he's changing the game.
And yet we had a couple people that I kind of thought were bottom feeders and I
was like,
you never get upset at them.
Like every,
I've never seen you get upset at these people.
How?
And he just said,
you know,
Peter,
I just look at everybody and I figure out at least one thing that they can do
well.
And I just figured out a way to empower them to do that one thing,
even if they can't do the 10 things that I would expect you to do.
I remember thinking,
I understand in theory what you're saying,
I can't do that.
I can't tolerate mediocrity.
So that was a huge thing that I learned.
Um,
and it never really hit home again until I was running a nonprofit because,
you know,
there wasn't a lot of mediocrity at Hopkins.
Right.
And you sort of had your pick of the best residents there.
Everybody there was the best at what they did.
You had amazing nurses,
amazing residents are amazing respiratory therapist and like everybody there was
like the best of their field,
right?
And then I go to Mckinsey,
same thing.
You've kind of got the best of the best all over again.
But you know,
fast forward five years,
I'm now running a nonprofit.
Well all of a sudden you don't get the best of the best anymore.
You're,
you're drawing from like the third pool.
And I remember coming back to that,
which is,
you know what,
you're probably not cut out to do this.
You have two choices.
Don't be a leader,
just be your own dude.
We're be a leader but only with a players.
But this notion of like you have the capacity to mentor the c players and maybe
turn them into a B plus player.
Like,
I don't have those jeans.
I can't do it.
And,
and not only that,
like I will destroy the c player and I don't mean to,
but I will bury them in the ground and,
and become a horrible human to them.
So,
so I also realize like I can be a really bad person.
Um,
if I don't,
if I don't respect the work that someone's willing to do.
So do you,
did,
did you or do you ever have to find a counter to that?
Cause like if you were in the military and you and I were working together,
I would be like,
Hey Peter,
did you gotta get you gotta get you gotta Act like Rosen?
What does that road,
you've got to act like him because in the military you're not getting a players.
I mean,
you've got some great guys,
even in the seal teams,
you got some great guys that are studied.
Got some.
Okay guys that are in the middle,
you've got some losers down at the bottom.
Guess what you need?
Every single one of them go on to talking with you and they all got to give you
what you,
everything made can.
And the more you create conflict with them and the more you are talking down to
them,
the less they're going to do there.
You know how they're already has a c level player,
a d level player.
Yeah.
They're going down there.
You're not,
you're not making them any better.
So that's a,
did you ever try and correct that or do you just go through and say,
you know what,
you've realized that that's like a weakness of yours.
Clear.
There were two attributes that you can be a c player in and I can cope with one
but I can't cope with the other and I accept it fully.
I can cope with someone who has a c plus intellect.
So if you think about the intellect is the CPU of the computer.
I don't need everybody to have the fastest CPU.
I accept the fact that like we all have different sort of innate capacities to,
to,
to sort of process and do.
And you know,
we all move at different speeds.
I can cope with variability there where I cannot cope with variability or maybe
I've just chosen,
I don't want to is I can't cope with variability on intent,
work ethic,
integrity like when you are,
if you can't be an a player there,
I actually don't want you in my life anymore.
And I think I'm old enough now that I've just said fuck it.
You know I'm not going to deal with it anymore.
Life is too short and I'm not going to deal with c players who,
who fail on those metrics.
I don't care how smart you are,
but if you can't show up and work your ass off,
if you can't be honest,
if you can't care,
if you can't want to get better,
I actually don't want you in my life.
So you're right.
I probably,
I mean I think I,
I'm probably not cut out to be a leader because I can't take those people who
are failing on those metrics and work with,
well you just need to be a leader of a very high performing team,
not of a regular regular to you.
Yeah.
I never had problems.
Right.
So when I was a resident,
you know,
residency is very hierarchical.
Right.
You know,
you've got the med student,
the sub I,
the intern,
the second year resident,
the senior resident,
the chief resident,
the fellow,
the attending.
I mean it's,
it's,
it's as clear as day in charge at any moment in time.
And as I'm going up through those ranks for the most part,
I never really had difficulty with the teams underneath me.
But again,
I had the luxury of being at Hopkins.
Everybody there is the best,
the med student,
they're the best,
the resident or the best Mckinsey's,
same thing,
you know,
you're dealing with the best of the best.
But Yeah,
running a nonprofit,
it was like a totally different world to me.
And so I think the difference is a great leader could have succeeded in any
environment.
You know,
they could have done it,
they could have figured out like okay,
the reason this person like acts like a lazy sack of Shit is actually because of
this.
And you can like figure out a way to like touch them and help them out of that.
And I was just like,
yeah,
I'm not doing it.
So that was,
so that's,
that's going back to NIH and you,
that was the first time you dealt with people.
First Time I'd sort of seen in a long term working environment,
like a couple people who weren't top agents.
And again maybe part of it's cause you're in the government at that point and
you get some staff people there maybe who you know.
And part of it,
I think it was just because Steve Rosenberg was such an amazing guy and he could
get the best out of everybody that he might've just had a greater tolerance for
that.
I think the second thing I learned was I would never be a world class scientist.
So when you go to NIH,
you're really only going for one reason.
I mean I'm sure there's some people that go there just to check the box and say,
I was at the Nih.
That wasn't why I went.
I went because Steve Rosenberg was my hero when I was in medical school.
I read his book called the transformed cell and I was like that book,
just know that book along with another book by you're getting Richard Fineman
called.
Surely you're joking.
Mr Feynman became kind of two of the most important books I read during my
twenties.
Um,
and actually wouldn't date somebody,
I wouldn't date a girl until she,
rather than,
oh,
we're going to go into it after,
after the podcast,
you and I are going to go to a full,
full on counseling session.
You need help.
So,
so
what's,
so I went to NIH because I was like,
look this,
you know,
this guy is my God and I want to be like that,
right?
I want to be the best surgeon scientists that ever lived.
And then I got there and I realized that surgery and science couldn't be more
different.
Surgery is the ultimate immediate gratification like surgery.
You get to fix the problem in hours.
Science is a lifetime of work,
a lifetime of failure before success is in fact,
one of the most remarkable stories from Rosenberg's book,
which of course I read well in medical school,
but it wasn't until a decade later when I'm living it that I really understood
why he was great and why I couldn't be great was from when he arrived at Nih in
1974 until he really had,
his first success was about 10 years.
So for 10 years,
everything he was trying was failing and every patient died.
Every single person that showed up died until this one woman in 1984 when
finally they figured out how to doe something called Interleukin two and they
finally sort of cracked the first piece of what has turned into a very long code
that 30 years later,
we're just starting to make really amazing traction on.
Now think about that for a second.
43 years ago,
he started that job for 10 straight years.
He just lost.
It's like you're going to go play pickup every day for 10 years and lose every
day.
So what I realized was actually I don't have that intestinal fortitude.
I cannot fail that frequently and still be at my best the next day.
And again,
I hate admitting that cause it sounds awful.
It sounds like I'm just,
I suck and I guess I suck.
But like I realized like I could be good.
I mean,
and I could go after easier problems to solve where you can like,
you know,
get grants and you know,
just play the game.
And that's frankly what most people do in this space.
But if you want to like change the game,
if you want to change mankind,
if you want to do something seminal,
you have to be willing to fail forever.
And I realized like I don't,
I find that ups,
again,
it's not that I'm addicted to the win,
it's not like,
oh I have to be told good boy,
good boy,
but I need someone,
I need to know that I have some control over my faith.
Whereas in surgery you have some control over your fate.
You know,
there is a difference between being a good surgeon and being a bad surgeon.
And it's not to say there's not a difference of you being a good scientist and a
great scientists,
but in science you are far less in control of what's going on then in surgery.
Now,
he must have had some longterm vision hypothesis that he absolutely believed it.
He laid it out.
He said there are four things that have to be true.
If we're going to ever figure out a way to get the immune system to fight
cancer,
these four things have to be true.
And if they're not true,
the immunes,
the human immune system,
we'll never be able to fight cancer.
And it took 10 years just to figure out the first proof of concept in a human.
So yes,
they had a couple of successes in mice where they had demonstrated,
okay,
like at least in Nice you can do this.
But in cancer biology,
you know,
you don't get terribly excited about doing stuff in mice for very long.
You know,
there's a really famous Italian cancer biologist who once famously said,
if you can't cure cancer in a mouse,
you need a new profession.
That's,
that's pretty low hanging fruit.
You,
you gotta be able do it in people.
So
it was while you were there that you would decide you weren't,
didn't want to go into medicine anymore.
Who gets
complicated,
right?
So then you're still,
I was still in the middle of my residency,
so what,
so then I went back to Hopkins to finish my surgical training,
but then I decided,
you know what,
I think I might actually go into cardiac surgery,
which I'd always been interested in.
So when I was in medical school,
I was really torn between cancer surgery and cardiac surgery and um,
you know,
to go into cancer surgery.
I think the real focus is going to be on research.
Like you want to,
you know,
you have to be involved in science and surgery.
Whereas I thought in cardiac surgery,
you know,
it's just pretty much the coolest surgery.
Like it's the most technically demanding surgery by far.
Um,
I shouldn't say by far,
I mean I think there are other things that are hardly on par technically,
but I was like,
I also came back in the mindset of,
you know what?
I'm just going to become like a great technician,
right?
I just,
and I loved opera.
I mean the heart is in one sense the simplest organ in the body.
Like it's really simple to understand what it's doing,
you know,
unlike the brain or the liver where it's just like 10 layers of complexity.
Like we kind of know what's going on with the heart and when it comes to
operating on it,
you know,
it's all a mechanical problem.
Like,
you know,
Oh,
this valve doesn't work.
this pipe doesn't work.
Oh,
this thing gives them,
or,
um,
but that was sort of my concession of,
well,
you know what,
you don't have to be the best surgeon scientists.
Why don't you just be the best surgeon?
Um,
because they are,
you're more in control,
right?
That's now just a function of how hard you want to work.
Um,
and that was,
that was,
that was shipper right up my alley.
And so then how did that path,
that drift to you don't want to do any of this anymore?
You know,
I think over the next couple of years,
I mean just a couple of things changed.
I mean,
one was,
you know,
I wasn't getting frustrated with these patients that we were talking about
earlier.
It wasn't the trauma patients that were getting to me.
There was something else that was getting to me that was much more frustrating,
which was the entire system.
It seemed like everything we did was this last ditch effort to put incredible
resources into a person's life at the very end.
And we didn't really move the needle that much.
Right.
So it just seemed like a broken system.
On the other end of the spectrum,
there's something else that did strike me as broken,
which actually contrasts or contradicts a little bit of what I said earlier.
I did feel that there was a subtle difference in the quality of residents.
So where there's this guy,
Chris on and day,
who's like the best resident that ever lived,
you know,
I think I was a good resident.
I think there were some other really good residents,
but there were others that just,
you know,
they were good but they weren't great.
And the thing about residency that really bugged me,
and I think part of this was I was watching my brother who was a lawyer,
so he came out of law school when I came out of medical school,
like we were at the same time.
And so I start residency when he starts this law practice or he joined like this
law firm.
And I remember seeing that it was a totally different world.
Like their promotions seemed more merit based.
Like they went up the ranks,
they got bonuses,
like
all these things happened that were functioning.
So my brother was like,
you know,
he was like breaking every record at his law firm,
right?
Like nobody could work as hard.
Nobody could bill as many hours.
Like nobody could like crush it like he could and he was being rewarded for it.
Now he ended up hating it.
He left.
He's now a public defender or a,
he's prosecuted rather.
So,
you know,
it takes a huge pay cut to go and become a prosecutor.
Cause that's what he really wanted to do.
But the point is he could have risen all the way up that chain.
And I remember thinking in residency,
I'm like,
we all get paid the same.
We all take the same number of years to get through.
It seems crazy to me.
Like there's no other system where this would be the case.
Like I couldn't think of another system where you just had this complete total
lack of meritocracy.
Um,
it was really hard to get fired from residency.
Like I saw some real knuckleheads do some real stupid things.
I never actually saw anybody get fired,
which is not to say you couldn't.
I'm sure you could.
Um,
but I felt like I was working a lot harder than was necessary because I just
wanted to be better.
And I thought,
God,
it's still crazy that this is going to take this many years to get through.
So,
so the,
and I also,
there's just a whole bunch of things about this system structurally that I
thought were completely broken.
And then on the other side,
I just felt like healthcare was completely broken as a system.
Right?
So we have this idea,
you know,
I don't remember the exact stats,
but you're going to spend like,
you know,
50 60% of your entire healthcare dollars in like the last year or two of your
life.
I mean,
something Asinine.
Right?
And,
uh,
so at the time
my wife said to me,
you know,
you are clearly upset about this system.
Uh,
I,
I think you have two choices.
You should either fix the system or leave it.
But I think that what you're doing now,
which is staying in the system and not changing it will probably not be
sustainable.
And so I think the toughest decision I ever made was at that point,
because I'm 30,
probably 32 33 I've invested 10 years into this and I'm thinking,
I want to do over,
I want a complete do over,
which,
you know,
everybody knows that the sunk cost fallacy is called the sunk cost fallacy for a
reason.
But it's still a damn compelling reason to keep doing something.
So,
so that was like a,
that was a super difficult time.
And you know,
in part you sort of feel like you're letting your mentor's down.
Cause a lot of people had invested a lot in me.
Right.
Hopkins had taken me,
right.
You're,
I was like one of the six chosen ones,
they only take six categorical is a year.
So now you're going to leave that program.
And there were,
you know,
a couple of attendings I'd become really close to who really believed in me and
really said like,
you're gonna,
you're going to do something really special.
And then to say,
actually I'm going to leave and I'm not even going to be a doctor anymore.
I'm just going to go in.
Yeah.
So then you roll straight to Mackenzie.
Well,
so,
so what I wanted to do is actually go back and get an Mba because,
uh,
I really,
the other thing I missed a lot in medicine was a,
I missed quantitative stuff.
Like I,
I missed math.
Like I miss being an engineer.
And the few times I tried to bring that into medicine,
I got spanked.
Right.
So you know,
there's one story.
I think I've talked about this maybe on a podcast before.
I don't think so though.
This is actually probably my first or second year.
I'm in the ICU taking care of this patient and there's patients on a very,
very toxic drug called gentamycin.
This is a drug that has to be dosed very carefully.
So if you give too much of it,
you can destroy their hearing permanently and destroy their kidneys permanently.
If you don't give enough of it,
the bacteria that you're trying to kill will kill them.
So you're,
you're,
you have a very narrow range in which to give the dose.
So there is no standard dose.
It's not like,
oh,
just take 875 milligrams of this every 12 hours.
Now it's take it first guess based on the patient's body weight,
so this many milligrams per kilogram,
give it to them and then measure a level.
And then once the level comes below a certain point,
give it again.
And I remember thinking,
it doesn't even make sense.
Like,
surely we know enough about the kinetics of this drug that we could build a
mathematical model to predict when to give it.
So I looked up,
you know,
a couple of papers,
a couple of books,
one night on call.
Sure enough,
I find like there's a very predictable alpha and Beta decay cycle for this drug.
So like literally an excel,
I build a model that uses a very simple differential equation and it needs a few
inputs and it will predict the kinetic curve of this.
And I'm like,
all right,
let's try it out.
So take one of my patients gonna be on Gentamycin.
I do everything the standard way,
but I plugged my numbers into the model to see what my model had predicted this
better and better.
And the answer was unquestionably.
So now I start to get a little confident in the idea.
So like the next night I'm like,
all right,
I'm actually going to start dosing the patient based on the model,
which never puts the patient in jeopardy because you're always going to check
the level before you dose,
but you're going to do so at the exact right moment.
And so my model predicted like at 4:31 AM this patient will Nader,
which means that's when you need to dose them.
So sure enough at like four in the morning,
I get the pay,
I asked the nurse to draw the patient's blood to confirm they're just about to
Nader.
We're going to reduce them in a way we go.
So next morning on rounds,
you know,
in the ICU you round as a big team,
I'm presenting that,
you know,
this patient is one of my patients and I start explaining that,
okay,
so the patient received their dose of Gentamycin at four 30 in the morning and
the attending says,
well what do you mean four 31 and we never dose Genta at four 30 in the morning.
We dose it at 7:00 AM always.
And I'm like,
yeah,
but the patient hit their nadir at four 30 it's like,
I don't care.
You know?
And so we got into this huge fight and like,
you know,
I almost got fired that that would've got me fired by the way,
find me,
someone gets fired,
someone gets fired.
And so I mean that hist me off beyond words.
Right.
It pissed me off that like,
it just struck me as so anti intellectual.
Maybe my model wasn't perfect.
We never know.
But the fact that nobody even cared to say,
is there a better way to do this?
That drove me that shit crazy.
And that's just one of many stories like that that happened through residency
where I was like,
it's almost like we want to live in the 1950s here.
And so,
so you have that sort of pain of problem solving is not valued.
At least it didn't seem valued to me.
It was valued in the lab,
but I had decided now I'm not going to be in the lab.
So here I live in this world where problem solving is not valued.
And I don't actually,
I'm not a quant anymore.
Like I don't do math anymore.
And I really loved math.
Um,
so I started,
so I started tutoring kids in math.
I made like a little bit of free time so I could like tutor high school kids in
calculus just to like get my calculus on again,
missing it.
But it wasn't the same.
So,
so then I was like,
you know,
maybe I'll go back and get an Mba.
So I looked into that,
didn't feel like I was already drowning in debt at that point in time.
You know,
you've got med school debt is sort of painful and you know,
residency you're making,
I think at the time were making about 34,000 bucks a year.
So it's,
you're not even putting a dent in your $200,000 debt sort of thing.
So,
so then I remember one night I was in,
I was on call and I was really pissed to be on call this night,
this and now you can relate to this better than I'll ever be able to relate to
it because I'm sure this happened to you your whole life.
But my best friend from high school tells me in February,
he's getting married that August,
and I'm the best man.
He lives in Toronto.
So he's like,
this is the date of my wedding.
I figured it was like August 5th it's a Saturday.
I want you to be the best manner,
completely honored.
So I tell my program director in February,
can I not be on call that day or the day before?
I just need to,
I need to be able to fly out to Baltimore on a Friday and come back on a Sunday.
And he's like,
Hey,
that's no problem.
I remind him three times.
No problem,
no problem,
no problem.
Sure enough,
the call schedule comes out.
I'm on call Saturday,
I'm on call the day of the wedding.
Like,
you've got to be kidding me.
So it's two o'clock that morning.
I'm down in the Er looking at a chest CT scan on a guy who I'm worried has it,
what's called a dissecting aorta.
And,
um,
the radiologist,
you know,
I,
I introduced myself and she's very nice and she sort of walks me through the CT
scan and then we just start shooting the breeze a little bit and she says,
Oh yeah,
you seem kind of down tonight.
What's up?
And I was like,
hi,
I'm just kind of pissed off.
I mean,
wish I wasn't here at Blah,
blah,
blah.
And,
and she's like,
yeah,
I can,
I can relate.
I used to be in a surgical residency myself and I was like,
oh,
really?
She goes,
yeah,
yeah.
I did my internship and surgery up at the University of Seattle and I just hated
it so much that I left and actually joined this company called Mckinsey.
I worked there for two years,
but then decided I wanted to come back to medicine.
So,
uh,
but I wanted to do it in sort of a kinder,
gentler way.
So that's why I'm back here doing radiology.
And I was like,
oh well what's this Mckinsey thing?
I'd never heard of it.
And so she told me all about it and I was like,
Huh,
that sounds interesting.
How do I apply?
You know?
And that was sort of the beginning of it.
So she introduced me to some folks and you know,
then I had to like study all over again cause to the way they interview at these
consulting firms is very specific and it's not you.
You can be the smartest dude in the world if you show up and you haven't thought
through how to solve a case like what are called these case interviews,
you're,
you're going to flail.
So you have to actually put in some like work and then study.
So I,
you know,
got a bunch of books on case interviews and I'd be sitting in the trauma bay
waiting for bodies to come in.
I'd be like reading my cases,
you know,
case interview things before.
So that,
that's,
that was sort of the transition.
And then you walk,
you walk out,
you walk away from medicine you'd go into,
so where are you doing medicine specific consulting.
So I was looking at rooted
to do that because Mckinsey,
um,
and I,
I'm sure this is true of like Bain and Bcg,
which are kind of the other two really big um,
management consulting firms.
Um,
they recruit about a third of their consultants who out of sort of what we call
non typical or atypical rather,
um,
backgrounds.
So people who have PhDs or jds or MDS,
but who didn't go to business school.
And then so they send you off to do business school that summer.
They do this and call it a mini Mba,
which was,
I mean it was like being a kid in a candy store again because I got to go spend
a whole summer in school again,
learning finance,
like learning all of these things that,
you know,
for some people might seem kind of dry,
but when you're like just dying to get back into numbers,
I was like,
oh my God.
Like,
you know,
I remember the first time we learned what was called the efficient frontier,
which is basically this differential equation that describes,
you know,
an investment philosophy.
I was like,
like,
I can't believe I'm doing this again.
I can't believe it.
So,
so then we show up for orientation.
I'm in San Francisco at this time.
That was the other thing I wanted to get back to California.
So I was like,
you know,
San Francisco,
please.
So during the first a drink during orientation week,
I was approached by one of the staffers there and they said,
hey,
you know,
your background looks like you've done a lot of mathematics.
I said,
yeah.
They said,
well,
you know,
we know you're a physician and you're probably here to work on,
the,
all the medical teams are going to try to grab you to have you work on some
biotech thing or whatever.
But,
um,
we have this,
banking issue that is very important to some of our clients and it requires an
ability to do stochastic calculus would,
would you be up for doing that?
And I was like,
of course.
And so then that was basically the beginning and I never really stopped doing
that stuff.
So,
so I ended up doing what's called credit risk modeling,
which then,
which started out around this thing called the Basel to accord,
which was a type of,
uh,
this was a regulation that came out in the mid two thousands that required banks
to hold a certain amount of capital against unexpected losses.
So banks have a long history of knowing how to hold capital for expected losses,
but they don't really know what to do for unexpected losses.
And in particular,
the problem that was damning was something called asset value correlations.
So,
um,
if you're a bank,
you,
you could have 27 lines of business,
you do first mortgage,
second mortgage,
Otto student credit card,
like you name it.
And the problem is nobody really understood how those assets correlated.
So if your loss rate is x in this,
what's the probability that it impacts the loss rate in that?
So where that,
where the rubber meets the road is,
if I can't make my house payment,
I'm probably not making my car payment either.
That's right.
And that's what nobody got to realized.
Everything went down.
Oh yeah.
Yeah.
So that turned into,
as we were in the midst of that,
because the,
because the banks used to leverage themselves so much that they could do well in
when the market crashed,
they weren't ready for it.
They couldn't handle it.
You know,
it's such an,
I mean,
it's like literally one of my favorite topics actually,
which are,
I'm sure your listeners don't want to get bored to tears on it,
but the first of all,
the best movie of all the movies that have like tried to explain what's going
on,
the big short by far does the best job because it actually explains the,
the sequence of events that went,
that took this from being just an isolated problem to a systemic problem.
Most people miss the subtlety of how this thing ceased to be contained,
as you know,
because technically a housing crisis shouldn't have affected the global economy.
So it was these instruments called CDOs that effectively allowed this problem to
become enormous.
But at the time,
the bigger issue was,
you know,
just a great example of Hubris that exists everywhere,
right?
Which is one we don't like looking at data that contradicts our point of view
and we're all guilty of this.
I'm guilty of this.
I find myself doing it and I actually am now quite amused.
I'm so attuned to it now that I'm quite immune.
It's like if I'm flipping through Twitter,
I'll see a story that is completely against how I feel and I don't want to read
it.
And then like the next one will be like exactly how I feel.
I want to read it.
And I'm like,
Dude,
look what you just did man.
You've got to stop,
pull back,
go assume you are wrong and keep going and try to figure out if you're but so,
so at the,
at the banking level,
I mean,
and we,
you know,
the,
the canary in the coal mine here,
while there were many,
but in 2000 early 2006 2000 yeah.
Mid 2006 we had,
when we were trying to do these asset correlations,
one of the biggest problems we had is we couldn't,
we only had 10 years of data.
The banks only had this data recorded for 10 years.
We didn't have losses to model.
And I remember saying to like,
you know,
the controller at this bank,
I'm like,
hey man,
like it's going to be really hard to build you a model of losses when you don't
have any historical losses.
And he goes,
well,
and that's mortgages.
Mortgages can't lose money,
right?
So that was,
and we can laugh at that now,
but at the time that was like not an unreasonable point of view,
right?
Like you can't lose money on a first mortgage.
Think about it.
You got to put 20% down.
You want to buy a home for a hundred grand,
you better show up with 20 you better be able to document.
You have a job,
you better do this,
you better do that.
You'd better do that.
So you now the bank's only on the hook for 80 on a home that's been legitimately
appraised for a hundred and you've shown documentation,
so you're at least going to pay that thing down to 70 such that worst case
scenario,
market falls by 10% houses worth 90 you lose your job,
guess who still gets paid the bank,
they still get their 70 sure.
If you're in the business of creating a second mortgage,
you take a little bit more risk,
but there's no reason you should have been losing money on first mortgages.
And so
you fast forward a year.
Well especially because,
don't worry about the value of the house cause that's going to go,
he's going to go up.
That's right.
So we're good to go.
Oh well that's where,
and I remember even when I was in Baltimore,
one of my buddies,
because you know the residents,
we're always looking for a way to make a buck on the side,
right?
When you're making 34 k a year,
you got it.
You got to come up with and the only saving grace as you can't spend money,
like your,
your closes free,
you're in scrubs all the time.
You're kind of eating for free all the time.
Cause I eat off the patients' trays,
whatever,
they didn't finish,
I like go to the nurse's station or eat all this crap.
So I didn't,
I didn't actually spend much money.
Um,
pens was like the only thing I wasted money on.
Like I collect mom blogs and so even through residency I would still buy these
beautiful pens.
So,
um,
so yeah,
I remember one of my buddies being like,
dude,
we got to start buying houses in Baltimore because like they're so cheap and you
can get them with no money down.
So you could buy a house for 200,000 bucks,
put like $5,000 down.
If that house goes up to two 20 you just made 25 k you made 20 k on your five.
We're going all the way and no one does the math of what if it goes down to one
90.
You just lost everything.
Right.
So luckily I didn't get it on any of those sweetheart deals.
Although if you time them right there,
a lot of people did make a lot of money on those deals before the shoe fell.
So when,
when the,
when things started to become clear,
so in early
in early oh seven,
it became clear sub subprime mortgages,
we're going to be a problem by August of Oh seven,
eight a very famous then famous analyst.
Uh,
what's her name?
Meredith Whitney I believe is her name.
I think she was at Oppenheimer called something that at the time seemed crazy.
She said,
Citi Group is going to cut its dividend next month.
So for city group,
you know,
huge,
one of the largest banks in the country to not pay a dividend for Q three seemed
impossible.
But she'd done the math.
She's like,
yeah,
there's no way they're getting,
they're getting crushed on these mortgage backed securities.
And everyone was like,
she doesn't know.
She's talking about sure enough,
Q3 comes along,
city cuts its dividend.
Chuck Prince,
the CEO of city gets fired.
And at that point it's like God damn.
But again,
everybody was still thinking this is just a sub prime problem.
It's an inch wide and yeah,
it's a mile deep,
but it's an inch wide.
Well,
in the background we're working on another problem which is prime mortgages,
that which everybody thinks is totally fine,
that which has a historical default ratio of less than half a percent and we're
seeing in the data the data that was right in front of this bank the whole time.
Oh,
there's a,
there's a tsunami coming.
Your default rate's going to hit four or 5% which again,
that might not sound like a lot.
That's 10 times your default rate.
It's going to be actually higher than that as we learned and your loss given a
default is going up much higher.
So loss is actually the dot product of probability of default and loss given
default.
Okay?
You guys are my only two customers.
Probability you default is 50% the probability you to faults 10% if you default,
you will lose 100,000 so it's 10% times 100,000 I expect to lose 10,000 on you
if you default.
It's 2000 so 50% times 2000 a thousand so my total expected losses 11,000 so
this is,
you know,
you do this 88 million times for every account you have.
And the model to predict probability to fault in loss given default are enormous
models that each have 50 variables in them.
Actually the PD does,
the LGD doesn't,
but what people didn't realize is the loss given defaults were skyrocketing.
It was like,
in fact,
again at the level of just being kind of a math idiot.
Like that to me was so amazing to watch,
right?
It was like,
Holy Shit,
watch these LGDs go.
They're just like blowing up like cheese.
And then you knew once the PD triggered,
meaning what's the probability of default went?
Oh,
it was,
it was going to become a nonlinear catastrophe and it turned out so November
15th Thursday,
November 15 2007 it was kind of the day like that was the matrix moment.
So I had a team,
great example.
I was able to be a leader for once because I had an amazing team.
I had a team in San Francisco of four people.
I had a team in India of four guys.
We worked around the clock 16 hours a day every day except Sundays.
We took off and we would pass the model back and forth to each other.
Amazing like it was like it was,
it was pure bliss to be working that hard on this problem.
And on that day we basically came up with four independent models that all
predicted how bad this thing was going to be and we presented it to the
leadership of this bank and it's really funny,
I was a manager,
so,
so it Mckinsey,
you have these levels like analyst,
associate manager,
junior partner,
partner director for a meeting of that stature,
meaning you're talking to the entire leadership of the bank.
The senior partner would only be the one to predict.
I'd be in the corner,
work in the PowerPoint answering a question if piped up because there's going to
be a technical question,
but the senior partner would do all the talking.
But on that day we go into the meeting and the senior partner says,
Peter,
you should present this.
And I said,
are you sure?
Cause I'm like the third most junior guy in the room here.
And he said,
yeah,
two reasons.
One,
you're the only one who actually understands how all of these models work.
And T and this is the funniest thing he said,
he goes to,
because of all of your experience with cancer patients,
you're going to be very good at answering hard questions about bad things
happening.
Wow.
And I was like,
okay.
So I stepped in and I did my best to be empathetic and nonjudgmental and like
just as evidenced fact based as I could.
And this is what this says and this is with it.
When you look at the run rate model and the PGD says this and the Lgd says this,
and the vintage model says this and you know here.
And so finally,
like the president of the bank says,
how much money are we going to lose?
Like she was kind of like,
you know,
like all good leaders.
She's just like,
just get,
tell me the God damn answer first.
So I said I had to think on my feet like pretty quickly about a way to put it in
terms.
So I said you're going to lose more money in the next 18 months than you've made
in the last 10 years.
And see the Jocko answer to that question,
how much money are we to lose would have been all of it.
That's what we're seeing you and me on Twitter.
Right?
Like you always have the best answer.
Like always cause that that would be like,
Hey John,
can you just picked it up on Twitter?
Like the CEO of the bank.
Hey Jakob,
how much money we're gonna lose all.
Look Peter,
one of three.
Well start with your Ebitda last year.
Multiply that by two of
three of three.
Did they,
they listened to you at all?
They want to believe that data.
Good.
I was impossible.
That was impossible to fathom.
Uh,
years later cause I had it by this point left Mckinsey.
But I stayed in close touch with that team and I reached back out to that senior
partner who,
um,
actually I'm still very close with you.
I just got an email from him two days ago.
I said,
hey man,
remember all those models?
Yeah,
yeah.
Did we,
where we roughly close?
And he goes oh no,
the model is underestimated by a third.
I mean I was like,
it seems like we kept trying to tone the models down cause they kept giving us
these answers and we were like,
damn,
like there's no way it can be this bad.
And we were like,
oh,
let's make this assumption more conservative and let's do this.
You know,
in the end it was like,
nope,
it was actually that bad.
Brutal.
So then,
now I remember I saw you tell a story one time.
It's on,
it's on youtube somewhere,
but you're talking about a patient you were working on,
you kind of alluded to this earlier,
you know,
either pre diabetic or diabetic and you're sitting there going,
you gotta be kidding me.
Cause the day before you tried to save someone's life,
that was,
you know,
a young kid.
And that was sort of it.
Was that the first time that you started thinking about nutrition as a,
you know,
and an earlier you talked about,
hey,
we do all this stuff at the end of the life,
it's all this prevention to prevent someone from actually dying.
But if we would have invested some of that money up front,
top these people out to eat,
we'd been better off.
Is that sort of where it came from or
not at all?
I mean,
I never made that connection at that time.
Right.
So at that time it was just what you described.
It was just the visceral reaction of I'm so angry at you.
How can you not take care of yourself?
How can you be sitting here?
So fat,
so diabetic,
you know,
over and over again,
you come in here to,
to have these ulcers debriefed it and to have these things amputated and you
know how the story's going to go.
Like just get it together.
So,
so this was,
I mean I didn't say those words,
but that's how I'm feeling.
Right.
And so that's,
that's just part of like the like the callousness that developed towards that
subset of patient.
It wasn't until
probably 2009.
Um,
so I'm out of medicine now,
but I was becoming overweight and I was pre diabetic.
I wasn't diabetic,
I was pre diabetic and I was,
you know,
that I was sort of come full circle.
Right.
And I was like,
wait a minute,
wait,
I do everything right.
I mean I'm swimming four hours a day,
I'm following that Goddamn food pyramid to the core and I don't need saturated
fat.
I'm like,
you know,
I,
I carb load like a band sheet.
Like why am I,
why is all this stuff happening to me?
And so,
so then when I went through my whole discovery process of figuring that out,
it was only then that I really thought back and reflected upon,
you know,
the horrible way I had treated,
not just that patient particular,
but that obviously many other patients like her.
I remember her case specifically because it was probably like the absolute low
point of my existence.
Um,
so unfortunately it took me sort of failing on my own because at least then I
could say this isn't a willpower problem.
It's not like you don't care.
It's not like you're not trying,
you're doing what you're told to do and you're failing miserably.
So either you're an outlier or maybe the advice is incorrect.
So you're eating what you're being told to eat,
your car bloating and you're still getting fat.
Yup.
And at this time you're swimming,
we were just talking about it before the podcast.
You're doing ultra long swims,
dozens of miles worth of swimming,
which by the way,
in seal training,
then basic seal training,
the longest you swim is five and a half nautical miles,
which is 6.2 statute miles,
which,
and that's with swim fins on.
So you're out there in the end,
you're out there in the open ocean swimming 12 1518 miles at a time,
and you're training for that working hard.
And you're quote unquote eating right because you're not eating saturated fat.
And yet you're getting fat.
You go into the doctor,
you get blood tests,
and they say,
oh yeah,
by the way,
you're prediabetic and you just say to yourself,
what is going on?
Yeah.
And truth be told,
I was actually more pissed just from the vanity standpoint at being fat.
I mean,
which I get for those of you on the podcast,
echo is nodding his head.
We did that.
I mean,
I wish I could say like,
oh,
it didn't bother me to be fat.
It did bother me to be fat.
It really bothered me to be fat.
Right?
It bothered me.
It bothered me a lot actually.
And so much so that I actually wanted to get a gastric bypass.
And so I went,
uh,
it's like,
so right now I'm about 175 I was like probably two or five to to 10.
It's again,
after this podcast,
you and I were going into counseling session.
So I went to,
I finally got my doctor to get me a referral to this guy named Ken Fujioka,
who's like a very prominent bariatric physician here in San Diego.
So I finally go to see Fujioka.
So I'm sitting in the waiting room and uh,
actually I think I told this story on Tim's podcast.
I don't remember telling you,
but it is in,
that's in the book.
It's in the his I think the stories.
Yeah.
So I,
but in the spirit of assuming nobody listens to or reads multiple other things,
so I'm in the waiting room,
I'm finally waiting to see,
and the nurse comes out and before you go back to the,
to the clinic room,
like you have to get weighed,
that's just part of the protocol,
right?
So like they call my name.
So I walk up and I get on the scale and the nurse comes out in ways me and it's
like,
you know,
whatever,
two 10 and she's like,
congratulations.
And I'm like,
what?
She goes,
you're postsurgery right?
And I'm like,
no,
I'm here to be evaluated for surgery.
She like looks at me,
looks out at the waiting room where everybody is 400 pounds and like doesn't say
a word,
but the look in her eyes is basically like what the Hell is wrong with you?
That yeah,
you got serious as your son,
but
it seemed like a reasonable idea.
Very reasonable,
very reasonable.
You might want to check your reasonable ideas with me for future because that is
not a reasonable idea.
So you get done.
You don't do that surgery obviously.
But what,
I had no patience for me.
What clicked in your brain?
Did you just all of a sudden say to yourself,
okay,
how is this happening?
And then you remembered your a and p class and said this is what's happening.
So I remember clear as day.
So,
uh,
September 7th,
2009 I did,
uh,
I sort of did like one of these long swims a year.
You know,
you do a bunch of short ones,
a bunch of training,
but you always haven't had one main event.
My main event this year was I went back to Catalina Island and I wanted to swim
from now la out to Catalina.
I had previously gone from Catalina to La and um,
it was tough swim.
I had a torn labrum,
so about six hours in,
you know,
it just became unbearable pain.
Um,
and you don't usually have a head current in the Catalina channel.
So the San Pedro Channel,
you know,
this,
you probably trained out there,
the currents usually running from point conception down or up.
So you usually have a little bit of a cross current and rare,
very rare to get anything back or forth.
And if anything,
it's generally a little bit towards the island.
And when I had swum four years earlier from Catalina to La,
it took 10 and a half hours.
But that was only 18 months after I learned how to swim.
I was a much better swimmer in 2009 and I was going in the theoretically faster
direction.
So a great example is expectations can kill you.
So I'm expecting this to be like a nine hour swim back.
And,
and really the only thing I'm thinking about,
which is the worst thing you think about in marathon swimming,
you should never,
ever,
ever think about how long this is going to take because you just,
you're just setting yourself up for misery.
The only real question has,
could I break nine hours?
You know,
I should be able to break nine hours.
Right?
So to make a long story short,
I don't even come close.
This is a total disaster scenario.
The other thing you,
you'll appreciate this just because you'll appreciate the stupidity.
Um,
you never want to look anywhere when you're swimming except down.
it's very demoralizing when you're in the middle.
Like if you're in the middle of the channel,
you don't see land from the water level.
You just,
you just don't.
So that's true.
So before you get on the water,
you tell the crew and every,
I've crew chief for a lot of great swimmers.
I mean,
it's the,
the,
the crew asks the swimmer,
what do you want?
What information do you want?
So we're starting to swim at midnight at point percent day.
I said,
okay,
I want to,
when there are exactly 10 miles to go and exactly four miles to go,
what's the total distance of the swim?
Well,
as the crow flies,
it's 21 um,
and if so,
you don't have a current,
you're doing a 21 miles swim.
If you do have a current,
you're going to swim more than that.
So,
so that's why I said,
I said,
guys,
I want to know when there's tend to go and four to go.
Why tend to go?
You're just a little over halfway.
I'd like to just know that at four to go,
it's put your head down and swim for two hours.
Don't do anything.
You're there.
So start the woman midnight.
This is in September,
so I forget what time the sun was rising back then,
but I knew that I would have tend to go before the sun came up.
So in other words,
I knew that once the light was up,
I was going to be inside the 10 stretch.
And one of the most amazing things about swimming in the middle of the ocean.
I don't know if you've got to experience this during training is in the Pacific.
The bio luminescence is so strong and so on a clear night,
which I was always lucky to have every time I swam out.
I've done a lot of the channels,
swims every time I've been out there I've always been blessed with these clear
nights.
It's so dark cause once you get out of Las light under the water so your hand is
coming down,
you are seeing the bio luminescence flare off your hands.
When you breathe you were seeing the stars.
You can't tell the difference.
It is so dark.
You cannot see the difference between stars and bioluminescence.
It's like being in this amazing chamber and so that's the,
that's the reward you get for swimming at night,
which is otherwise incredibly lonely.
And then the first thing you notice is the bio luminescence gets harder and
harder to see,
which means,
oh the sun's going to be up in an hour.
The Sun comes up.
Now the sun's like up there.
I haven't heard anything.
And I'm like,
those guys,
they forgot to tell me I've got 10 to go.
That's okay.
Probably down to six to go now.
And I'm swimming,
I'm swimming.
I'm assuming it must be like 10 o'clock in the,
I mean I'm being facetious,
it's probably like eight 30 in the morning and they're like 10 to go.
And I was like she's us.
And cause at that point I had no clue what the current was like cause a swimmer
can't feel current.
Right.
Just can only feel relative velocity,
not absolute velocity.
So you know that coupled with the torn labrum coupled with like it ended up
being over 14 hours of swimming and there's a very long story because your
question was so simple.
But I remember getting on the boat,
I don't even remember what my question,
your question was about Patricia,
about like when I finally decided this was the day that was over here in bio
luminescence.
Bill.
Okay.
So this is the day,
finished the swim,
get back back
to the boat and they've got like two burgers and two cokes waiting for me.
And I mean like I couldn't have eaten those things quicker.
Like the biggest juiciest burgers you've ever seen.
Like the cokes,
like they tasted so good.
Right?
Because you know your mouth is so salty,
you actually really wants him to suite.
And my wife,
my wife hates when I tell this story cause she denies that she said it,
but she completely said it.
I'm just sitting there like raw.
I remember this,
I have a picture of the burger fatty.
I've got like a USA towel wrapped around my waist.
Inhaling,
I come to fisting Burgers,
drinking my cokes and she just looks at me and she goes,
and again,
just in the sweetest way possible,
she said,
you,
you should probably work on being a little less,
not thin.
Wow.
Is that like the kindest way to just tell somebody you're kind of getting a
little fat,
almost 14 hours swim?
So that was the last time I had a coke.
Yeah.
I've never had a coke since.
Um,
and,
and all I did frankly at the time was just saying like,
I'm just going to try and experiment because I was like,
look,
at that time I still thought it was just calories in,
calories out.
I thought it was really just simple arithmetic and my view was,
all right,
I can't do anything more on the calories outside.
There's only 168 hours in a week.
I'm not willing to exercise more than 28 of them,
so calories out.
I don't get to change that anymore.
And frankly,
I didn't really want to change the calories inside cause I hated being hungry
every time I tried to eat less,
I would just be so hungry.
I didn't know what to do with myself.
So I was like,
I'm going to try a new experiment.
What if it's the type of Calgary that might matter?
Sugar strikes me as not great for you,
even though I can't tell you why I'm going to stop having sugar.
So that was my first experiment in September of [inaudible] nine,
and that led to everything that's come since that time,
which obviously ultimately led to me coming back to medicine as well.
Yeah.
And that's where you're at now.
And,
and,
and by the way,
um,
listening to Tim Tim's podcast,
what else should people listen to to get all that nutritional information?
Does the rest of the story?
I think it's Sam's.
Yeah.
I mean a couple of things with Tim.
Um,
I did a podcast with Chris Kresser,
um,
earlier this year.
Talked about longevity a little bit.
I did one,
I did,
I probably have maybe,
Oh,
you know what?
Probably you get more into nutrition.
There's an IHMC video I did probably like three or four years ago.
That one's like an hour long and you go pretty detailed in it.
Yup.
Okay.
Yeah,
I've watched that one.
Yeah.
Yeah,
those are good.
Those are good.
And again,
if you had to kind of
tell people that aren't going to go listen to those podcasts,
aren't going to watch that,
that video,
what would you tell them?
You know,
what would you tell him to eat overall?
I generally don't like talking about nutrition because,
uh,
and don't worry,
I will answer this question,
but I know at least preface it,
why I don't like it.
I don't like talking about this stuff.
Um,
nutrition is kind of a pseudoscience that masquerades as a religion for many
people.
And so I find it difficult to have a discussion about biochemistry when it's so
cloaked in emotion,
religion,
and dogma.
Now that's not to say I don't have a strong point of view.
I certainly do.
It's also an evolving point of view.
I feel different today than I felt four or five years ago.
Uh,
feel different than I than I felt two years ago.
And also my life is one big experiment,
right?
So,
you know,
we were joking before I came in here and I've got a glucose meter buried within
me at the moment.
I've got like all these heart rate variability things like everything I'm doing.
Actually,
let me just check them.
I actually did an experiment before I came here today.
I ate something and I want to see how much it raised my blood sugar.
What did you eat?
So I ate this product that I've been doing some research on.
It's called no k,
n,
O,
w like no foods.
And I was introduced to this product by one of my patients who said,
Hey Peter,
I want you to kick the tires on this a little bit.
It's um,
it's,
it uses a sugar substitute called [inaudible] and it tastes amazing and
apparently like it doesn't raise your blood sugar at all.
And I was like,
yeah,
I'm familiar with Al yellows.
Uh,
for,
for those who might not know,
[inaudible] is a sugar that occurs in nature in very small quantities that looks
exactly like this sugar called fructose,
which is fruit sugar,
the sweet component,
sugar with one small exception.
But that one small exception carries with it some very important things.
One,
it's not quite as sweet as fructose.
It's about 70% of sweet.
But by giving up a little bit of that sweetness,
you get a whole bunch of stuff in return.
First of all,
it's not metabolized by the liver,
which is the real problem for it goes to,
you barely absorb it.
So 99% of it or more or less as excreted by the kidneys.
And three,
it actually seems to lower blood glucose.
So this company,
no foods is putting this like making stuff out of this,
but stuff that is like carby like bread and waffles and muffins and stuff.
So anyway,
to make a long story short,
I met this patient's house and he's forced feeding me these things,
which is really my way of saying he's left the bag open and I'm inhaling them
and he's like,
yeah,
you gotta,
you gotta like tell me if this stuff's legit.
So to make a long story short,
he plugs me into the guy who founded the company and he has sent me a bunch of
this stuff to just play with cause he knows what I do.
And so that's what I've been doing.
So today I normally don't eat breakfast.
So I worked out this morning and then before I came here,
I had a big piece of their toast covered in almond butter and then two of their
huge waffles covered with almond butter and bananas.
Like I made a big sandwich out of that.
So the almond butter not going to have a huge glycaemic response because it's
got so much fat and protein in it,
but the bananas should skyrocket my blood sugar,
not to mention the two fricking waffles the size of my head and the piece of
toast.
So interestingly,
so that was at nine o'clock that I ate those and I've been up since three 30 but
I didn't eat anything.
I worked out from seven to eight.
So admittedly there's a bit of a glycogen debt.
So at nine o'clock when I ingested my blood glucose was 65 and at its peak,
which was 11:18 AM it was up to 90 and it's now down to 83 what would real
waffles have done to you?
I think they would have sent me to like one 43 huge pieces of bread slash waffle
with the full banana.
So anyway,
I've been doing these experiments all week,
which is just a great excuse to eat this stuff and I'm kind of actually
surprised.
I'm kind of blown away.
So,
okay.
With all that said,
what's my advice for what people should eat?
In an ideal world,
everybody would have this thing embedded in them.
Like I do.
This thing is called a Dexcom g five.
It's a continuous glucose monitor.
Um,
typically only used by people with type one diabetes.
we're now starting to see people with type two diabetes where them,
but,
um,
I was really completely lucky one day sitting on an airplane next to a dude who
happened to be into watches.
I'm into watches,
we got talking about watches.
I find out he's the CEO of the company that makes this thing.
The rest is history,
right?
I'm like obsessed with this stuff.
And so because the answer is this,
right?
If you were a computer program,
I would say Jocko eat whatever you want to eat such that your average blood
glucose remains below 85 milligrams per deciliter and your standard deviation
below 10 milligrams per deciliter.
So translate that into English.
Okay.
So eat in whatever way your genetics and epigenetics permit you to such that
your glucose levels stay low and the variability stays low and those two things
will ensure that your insulin levels stay low.
So what I'm trying to do is optimize for something called the insulin AUC or
area under the curve than we can't measure that test clinically.
Only I could measure that.
It's put you in a hospital,
put a central line in your neck and excuse me,
sample your blood every 30 minutes over the course of a day where you somehow
act normally and every day.
So then I'd have a time axis y axis,
the x axis to be time.
The Y axis would be insulin level and we generate a curve and we'd calculate the
area under that curve and we want that number to be as low as possible.
So we can't do that outside of the research setting.
So then the next best thing is keep your average glucose is low as possible and
the variability.
So you could have an average glucose of a hundred with low variability.
And that actually wouldn't produce that much insulin or you could have a glucose
of a hundred with high variability,
same average glucose,
higher variability is going to have higher insulin,
all things equal.
So just through empirical testing in myself over the past year and a half,
I've realized that an average blood glucose and this thing tells me every time I
hit click,
like it gives me my last 14 days,
I just realized like for my average to be below 85 and my standard deviation to
be below 10 is like super dialed in.
So what you can eat to achieve that varies tremendously by individual.
Um,
you know,
there are some people who just dispose of glucose remarkably.
So that blood tests we're going to do next week is going to be our best test at
measuring that.
Um,
and so,
so glucose disposal is as mostly a function of the insulin sensitivity of the
muscle because the muscle is where we dispose of the majority of glucose.
Um,
but it's more a little more complicated than that.
Right?
Sleep impacts that.
So sleep deprivation makes us more insulin resistant though.
This has been experimentally demonstrated even with two weeks of sleep
deprivation.
So there's a,
it's a small but very well controlled experiment that was done out of the
University of Chicago price six years ago.
They took a very small number of subjects,
like I said,
about eight subjects,
and for two weeks let them only sleep four hours a night.
And they did,
um,
a very invasive tests called a euglycemic insulin clamp at the beginning.
And at the end of the experiment and their insulin sensitivity,
their glucose disposal deteriorated by 50%,
and with no change in what they were eating.
So,
um,
so it's highly variable,
right?
So that's theoretically the answer.
On a practical level,
I would say the answer is this,
right?
If it comes in a package,
you're probably better off not eating it,
right?
Um,
if your ancestors couldn't have eaten this even 200 years ago,
it's probably not worth eating.
So if you just follow that advice,
think about how many things you'd eliminate from your diet,
right?
If you just took packaged foods away from your diet.
And again,
notice I'm agnostic.
You want to be a Vegan,
knock yourself out.
Do you want to be the Paleo Man of the century?
Go for it.
I don't give a shit.
Okay.
Like I couldn't care less.
Right.
But if you can largely adhere to those principles,
you're kind of going to be fine.
Do you want,
you know,
you're going to get 70% of the way there.
You want to get 80,
90,
100% of the way there.
Yeah.
Well then there's no simple answer.
Now at that point,
you got to dial in and you gotta go full immersion into how do you tweak to your
biochemistry?
How much protein,
what's the timing of the meals?
When do we fast?
I mean,
all of the stuff that,
uh,
is,
is my world and maybe soon to be your,
uh,
that,
that's,
um,
that's the,
that's the stuff for which you cannot provide,
you know,
systemic advice.
But at the,
at the societal level or at the,
just the most basic level.
Yeah.
I mean,
think about that advice.
Like,
you don't,
you don't eat sugar anymore.
You won't eat refined carbohydrates anymore.
You're not going to eat,
you know,
processed crappy foods anymore.
What are you going to eat?
You're gonna eat fruits,
you're going to eat vegetables,
you're going to eat meat,
you're going to eat grains.
You know,
what kind of grades are you going to eat?
Well,
you know,
you're,
you're not going to really eat these sort of refined crappy grains that people
that you're going to,
you know,
your,
your starches,
I'm sorry,
not grades.
Your starches are probably gonna be in the form of potatoes and rice.
So Again,
a lot of pee.
You know,
I just,
I sort of,
I think the reason I'm only talking about nutrition anymore is I don't find it
to be at an intellectually honest discussion anymore.
I find it to be just a discussion of dogma,
right?
So if you're a low carb camp,
you're a low carb camp.
If you're in the,
you know,
whatever the Vegan camp,
you're in the Vegan camp,
like there's the,
you can't even have a discussion about this stuff.
And at least not with most people.
So I just,
you know,
you ever read the book called Diet Cults?
Uh,
no.
So does it get into this nonsense?
That's the whole book really.
So interesting.
Fond to read.
Oh good.
All right.
We'll have to check that out.
And I called now kind of open with us and since we're,
since we're a little over two hours right now,
uh,
I said that you're probably the most responsible individual for this podcast and
because you originally through Kirk,
uh,
sent me up to do a podcast with Tim Ferriss,
which sent me up to do a podcast with Joe Rogan,
which was just all awesome.
And both those guys told me I should do my own podcast.
So anyone that's listening to this podcast say thanks to Peter for that.
Actually they should thank Kirk,
right?
Because,
and Kirk was the man,
you know,
I mean Kirk is,
I don't need to tell you,
but Kirk's one of those guys were like,
he doesn't have to justify an ask.
Right.
So when he introduced me to you,
he didn't have to explain.
He was just like,
I want you to meet Jocko.
Jocko is my friend.
I was like,
that's good enough.
And so in a,
to me like that's the measure of when life is good and because I feel that way
with all of my friends.
Like if Tim introduces me to somebody,
like Tim's introduced me to like a dozen people that does an amazing
relationships have come out of that.
Right.
And so,
you know,
really it was just very easy for me to sort of take Kirk on his word that like
if you know,
Jack has great guide,
then that's,
that's all I needed to know.
I knew you were going to be a great guy.
And then similarly,
like I could tell Tim like,
hey,
you gotta meet Jocko and,
and you know,
Tim gets quote unquote pitched all day long,
but you know,
he knows that I'm,
I'm not going to send them somebody that's not going to be really interesting
and going to benefit his listeners,
not just,
you know,
whatever agenda that person might have.
Yeah,
no,
it was awesome.
And that that really did,
I mean the way Tim,
you're way Tim
advised the way he was going to release the podcast in order to support them in
bulk.
I mean he just nailed it.
It was kind of ridiculous the way he understands that stuff and how helpful it
was to,
you know,
get in our book out there and getting it sold and,
and all that and getting all these people on board.
And then,
you know,
that turned it into this podcast,
which,
you know,
he,
he definitely has promoted the podcast and a fantastic way along with Joe.
So that's both been awesome.
But again,
started with Kirk connected me with you and then you connected me with Tim.
So,
uh,
appreciate that.
And I'm speaking to this podcast,
my almost silent partner over here that go,
Charles,
if somebody wants to support the podcast,
how would you recommend they go ahead and do that?
You'll always have a question.
Oh,
oh.
How'd you hurt your back or regionally?
No,
I don't think we ever really have a diagnosis.
There were certainly nothing on that day that I did that day.
I'm riding my bike to the,
to the gym.
I,
you know,
I think about the sins of my youth.
Um,
you know,
I was really into martial arts in addition to boxing and I used to spend a ton
of time,
um,
I was really obsessed with spinning back kicks.
Now I don't know if that could have done it or not.
I,
but I used to practice 75 spinning back kicks with each leg every single day for
probably about six years,
seven years.
Um,
it's possible,
even though in theory a spinning back kick,
if done correctly,
should really not put any torque on the lower back.
It's much more in your hips and technically the flexibilities in the thoracic
spine,
not the lumbar spine,
but you know,
God knows,
maybe I just wasn't doing those things correctly.
Um,
I did squat and dead lift really heavy growing up.
I did power lifting as sort of a side sport,
but you know,
certainly never hurt myself doing that.
I rowed crew for a year.
And so I always,
I've always wondered if that was the most destructive thing I did because I'm in
an eight man boat.
It's eight your asymmetric,
right?
So when you scull your symmetric,
when you sweep your not,
and so I was like,
I was a sweeper.
And so I almost wonder if like that's the most destructive thing I ever did.
Yeah.
And then you figure if you're asymmetric lake that your everyday life is
asymmetric really.
Cause you have a little bit of over developmental insight.
It might have been.
So I guess I'd never really known,
but I take it really seriously today.
In fact,
you know,
Jocko,
you'll dig this.
Two weeks ago I did a video in New York with a friend of mine named Jessie
Schwartzman and uh,
he's like,
I call him the savant of movement.
It's guys like,
just like the kinesthetic man.
And,
um,
I wanted to put a video together of how do you train to train,
how do you prepare your body to train?
So it's basically three sections.
It's,
um,
what,
uh,
what's the sort of dynamic while the sort of tissue preparation,
the static prep and the dynamic prep?
It took us eight [inaudible] maybe six hours to shoot this video.
It'll be edited down into probably three 10 minute videos.
And as soon as they're done editing,
I'm just gonna throw them up on youtube and my blog.
So I'll make sure you've got a copy.
It's,
it's,
uh,
I mean Jesse is just,
you know,
he walks me through all the exercises,
but I get the sense like if I had done that stuff all the way in my life,
I probably never would have been hurt.
And luckily,
knock on wood to this day,
I mean,
I never thought I'd be able to squat and dead lift again after going through
that year of my life.
But amazingly,
I,
I'm totally fine.
And who's a herniated disk that popped off?
Yeah,
so it was an l five s one really big herniation,
but then,
uh,
four or five centimeter fragment broke off and then floats down the canal and
that was sitting on the nerve root.
And then I developed a few other problems after.
So I developed this thing called a fossette arthropathy,
which resulted in the feeling of having my testicles torn out from the inside.
I'm not even joking.
That's just so it's just unbearable.
Yeah,
I would imagine that's unbearable.
I don't recommend that.
No.
All right.
Um,
well that being said,
I guess we can talk about some so you can talk about on it.
I was talking with Greg and Terry [inaudible] and I was showing them about,
uh,
I was showing him the warrior bars.
Right,
right.
These are,
these are dope.
And then,
then he was like,
oh yeah,
like what else is there?
There's some good songs as good stuff.
So I brought out the new preworkout one,
which is good,
by the way.
I have a report on that.
So that one comes out and then,
uh,
the Krill oil comes out.
Oh yeah,
this is good for this.
So we're talking about this,
this big table,
like all the sub,
it's not a lot.
It's like four things that worry bar cause of Krill oil and the preworkout and,
uh,
three things.
And we're like,
yeah,
this does this and this does this.
And then I kind of stepped back and I'm like,
yeah,
we're those guys with all our supplements talking about supplements,
talking about supplements,
right.
Which I've never done.
And Greg goes,
yeah,
if we weren't such nice guys,
this would be a real douchey conversation.
So the kind of the irony there is him saying that he's the one having the
douchey conversation,
but he is the nice guy.
You get it.
I guess.
So anyway,
point there or actually the second point there is on it is good supplements.
So if you do talk about it while you're taking them,
you're not having a douchey conversation.
And this is why I heard Joe Rogan talking the other day about how hard it is
when you're a standup comedian and you tell a joke and it just flat.
I think we just got,
here's the thing,
just getting your mercy last night I didn't do it because I'm not a merciful
person that had joking elements.
But this is true in this part of the bigger point that I'm making.
I hope so.
Everything I say,
even though you pretty much do
anyway.
The reason that,
not a douchey conversation.
Here's the point,
is because on it supplements the Krill oil,
all that stuff is actually good quality.
It's not like,
Hey,
I'm going to meet it,
I'm gonna get buff and all this stuff.
It actually helps your performance anyway,
so in the event of you wanting on it stuff and supporting this podcast,
while@thesametimesupportingyourselfgoingonat.com slash Jocko 10% off,
boom.
Second way to support Amazon,
click through Christmas is over,
but we still need stuff,
duct tape,
whatever,
nice,
et cetera.
Um,
if you want to support this podcast,
just go to the website chocolate podcast.com.
Click through the
Amazon banner link before you do your shopping.
You can support that way.
It's a good way to support,
oh wait,
yeah,
you're into chemistry,
right?
Sodium,
when you put a little piece of sodium in the water,
right?
It makes this big commotion.
So that's what kind of what the Amazon Click through does.
It seems like the small little thing but applied properly,
it makes a big impact in the podcast support wise.
Anyway.
I thought you'd get to reverify that doctor,
I will have to go and look at the Amazon Click through.
I tell Jack that he typically doesn't really understand cause he doesn't know
what sodium does.
No,
it might've been potassium or both actually.
So now this whole thing has been a lie.
I'm sure not and I'm pretty sure I haven't actually fairly surgeon.
Pretty sure it goes a long way with that girl I guess.
Anyway,
you can subscribe to the podcast on Itunes,
which seems obvious cause typically the podcasts you listened to,
you subscribed to,
but sometimes you don't.
So subscribe if you have not already and you want to support this podcast,
Google play,
stitcher also in the game.
Yeah.
And iTunes.
It's kind of unfair that I don't think about that as much.
You know when you have an iPhone and I can kind of forget all this other stuff,
we're here to help out.
Yeah man.
Good thing you're here on this podcast.
A Youtube of course working on putting more videos on there aside from the whole
podcast.
So some of those videos and I have gotten like messages saying like those
shorter clips are helpful.
They are,
you know,
rather than listening to the podcast people that have been submitting to you on
Twitter,
which excerpts yeah.
Are in high demand out there in the world.
Yeah.
I've been following now and in fact to have them all like it's a,
it's a process,
but yeah,
we're working on that.
So subscribe to Youtube.
We are working on that.
We are collective just so you guys know,
I'm not working on any of that,
but echo and buried vias,
which is cool technically you saying,
hey,
I put this one.
Okay.
Yeah man.
Exactly.
Um,
and then in the event of you wearing like what?
Like a t shirt or something or a hoodie.
Jocko has this store,
it's called Jocko store.
The URL is Jocko store economics of it.
Is that a calculator?
Watch you though.
I was going to get to that.
So you mentioned,
see now we've got to change the subject real quick,
which I like.
By the way,
remember you were talking about your into watches,
right?
I was going to shut,
I didn't want to interrupt what you're saying,
but that is,
I appreciate that.
That is re Dick Hillis.
I just reincorporated uh,
this one back because what is it,
our calculator watch?
Actually one of the first pictures I posted on Twitter was up before the enemy
and it was like,
you know,
Jack was always like,
yeah,
4:30 AM which one is at the Casio a Casio
circa 1984 85 that watch when I was a kid.
Dude,
like
for that,
only the cool kids had the calculator one.
Usually if you had to watch it was just the regular Casio and the cool kids had
the Kalki
first iron man.
Did you?
Yeah,
it was black with a leg,
a little red trim on it.
I asked for it for Christmas.
My parents got it for me,
but I knew where they had presence.
Every day after school.
I would go into their room and I would take it out of the box I had set the time
I would wear it.
I would just hang out there and then before I go to bed I would like sneak pack,
put it in and so like on Christmas Day it was like I'd been wearing a watch for
a month.
Right.
Those you're watching actually,
I think you got it.
Yeah.
Well I got one actually got,
I got quite a few of these shotguns.
You should have your own brand of watch and we'll see how all that turns out.
Yeah.
Nonetheless.
I am very proud of this calculator watch.
It's back to the store though.
Jocko store.
No watches,
but yeah,
yeah,
our yet.
Yeah.
Not yet.
But there are some cool shirts in my opinion.
I think they're cool.
Discipline equals freedom,
all these things.
Chocolates,
head good,
written in backwards.
Various layers to the shirts.
Not just like,
oh,
picture.
That's it.
So if you like any of that stuff,
I'm not even saying go buy this stuff.
I'm not saying that.
Just go to the chocolate store.com.
See if you like it.
If you like it,
you want one thing,
you buy one and that's the of the podcast.
You know it's a systemic thing.
Good.
There you go.
Patches on there as well.
Rash guards or shirts or you know what you didn't mention that you should have
mentioned cause apparently it's been pretty cool out there in the world.
Laid on me.
Psychological warfare.
Yeah I didn't mention it this time but I mentioned it last time and in my
everyday life and I use it so there you go.
Psychological warfare,
you use it.
I use it every day when needed.
Here's the thing,
you can't use it every day.
We didn't know you can't actually you can't,
I'm not gonna say you can't use it everyday,
but reason,
the whole
reason that I was like,
Hey Jocko,
what do you say?
You know when you're,
I need it everyday.
But it varies from season to season.
So like personally if you are coming up against moments of weakness.
Yup.
We have a little method to get you over those humps.
Yeah.
It's kind of like coaching a little bit because you didn't go pathic coaching
cycle for sure.
It cause it kind of at the state for,
I played one of them for my seven year old daughter the other day because she
was about to eat some candy or something.
I was like come here for a minute.
So I played her that one.
You know the snack time one?
Yep.
Sugarcoated science.
Yeah.
Sugarcoated lies.
She was,
she was pretty impressed.
But what impressed me was later in the evening she was kind of saying it.
Yeah.
See and that's what I was going to say,
where you explain,
it's like cool,
it's Jocko telling me to do this.
So yes I'll do it or not do it or whatever.
But you explained some,
some,
some good stuff like to remember,
you know like the news sugarcoated lives and that's kind of catchy too,
so it sticks in your mind.
So you can buy that on iTunes.
It's somewhere else too,
right?
Google play if you want it,
and also everyone that asks for an alarm tone to wake up.
That's it.
It's there now.
Don't have to ask anymore.
You can just go to iTunes and get that psychological or clear with your wife or
whoever you sleep with.
Yeah,
we've gotten some serious feedback on that one.
because what happens is the alarm goes off.
If you have it set,
then it's going to be my voice and it's gonna be weird because it sounds like
there's some strange man in your room till four 30 in the morning,
which is kind of weird.
Lonely work at 4:30 AM like,
no,
it's just,
it's just a,
it's an album.
It's a,
it's an album of tracks and each track talks about some moment of week,
generally a moment of weakness that you have.
Like there's ones to wake up in the morning.
There's ones too.
You know what?
You don't feel like going to the gym,
go to the gym.
There's ones you feel like eat a donut,
don't eat the donut.
There's one element.
I'm going to put this off for a while,
I'm going to procrastinate.
No,
you're not going to procrastinate.
So all the little moments of weakness that we all have as humans can be
countered using psychological warfare.
You actually,
yeah,
there's definitely two on there.
There's one called,
I think it's called like no more.
It's basically like,
I'm not doing this anymore.
No more a good one.
That one's good because it puts into words exactly like what you want to think.
Like,
you know,
cause you always feel that like,
you know how like,
you know you're gaining some weight or,
I mean a lot of times you know why you're gaining weight and so it's little bit
different,
but you're like,
you know what I'm not doing,
I'll,
drinking is one where you wake up,
kind of hung over and you're like,
I'm not drinking anymore.
You,
I like that thing,
but you never really executed and it's perfect because it sticks with you.
You're like no more.
And then the other one was,
um,
when you're talking about every day,
it's called every day,
every day.
Every day's a Monday.
That that,
that one was dope man.
So you can get after that.
Also if you want to get some tea,
if you're a tea drinker or if you're not a tea drinker,
you can get some Jocko white tea.
You can get it on Amazon.
It's fully in stock.
Yelled those days of being out of stock.
I think we've got them under control for now and I won't make any promises.
Cause last time I made a promise you guys went psycho.
So I'm not gonna make a promise,
but you can get the Jocko white tea.
I figured out again it doesn't,
it doesn't taste like tea really.
It doesn't taste like coffee.
And for a long time I was at a loss for words to describe what it tasted like
and I figured it out.
I was responding to someone and I figured it out what it tastes like.
And it's pretty simple.
The Jocko white tea tastes like victory.
So if you need to,
we need to train.
I need to trademark that one stat.
The fact then Jocko white tea tastes like victory.
Boom.
So get some of that if you need to.
Dead lift more.
If you need to.
Overhead squat more weight,
this will increase all those numbers beyond anything you could have hoped for.
You can drink it from a Jocko mug.
It says get after it on it.
That's good oversight by the way.
Yeah,
it's big.
It's big.
It's not somebody,
somebody made the comment that it's not comically big.
It's not a joke yet.
It's not like clown shoes
did it,
but it's big enough to,
you know,
it's a bit like a pair of work boots.
As big as a pair of work boots,
it will kick you in the ass.
So it's that big.
If you haven't got the book,
extreme ownership,
you can pick that up there.
It's about leadership.
It's about combat leadership.
I'm going to give my friend Peter Attia about three copies of it just to make
sure he reads it.
So if he has to deal with any c players,
you going to step up his game.
A a free publication.
That's right.
That's really pre-public.
What does that mean?
Before the book came out,
Hey,
here's what the book is.
Okay,
but it's still,
that's it.
That's what you got there.
Pretty quick combat.
Yeah.
At the VIP kitty screening,
um,
Hey,
speaking of extreme ownership,
we're having another monster.
If you don't know what it is,
check out the website.
Extreme ownership.com it's going to be in New York City so everyone can come.
Cause if you're on the east coast,
no matter where you are on the world,
it's easy to get to New York and
May 4th and fifth if you're a leader or you want to be a leader,
come and get it.
There's every level leaders,
their CEOs,
mid level managers,
every industry.
You can think of two people that are manufacturing and finance and construction
and health and pharmaceutical and there's police there and fire and military and
oil industry and entities to everybody all
working on leadership,
talking about leadership.
So,
and I've said it's gonna sell out.
We're moving in that direction quickly.
And Echo hasn't even released his videos yet cause he's on Hawaiian time.
No,
no you're not.
I'm working diligently and I'm going for quality.
Not,
you know,
you're not going to put out any scrub material.
Once those videos come out,
my feeling is going to sell it very quickly.
So get there now.
Sign up for it.
If you need a police or fire discount or military discount or if you're going to
bring a group of people.
I think the biggest group we had the last room for one company was around 16
people from one company or 12 people.
But there's some pretty big numbers of companies that are showing up there.
Come and come and get it.
Echo.
You've got any closing comments?
My pleasure.
Oh no other clues and comments.
Thank you.
Other than it was your pleasure.
Peter.
Any closing comments?
I would only echo echos,
comment and that didn't even get planned until it came out.
Perfect.
And if you want to continue these conversations with Peter on Twitter,
you're Peter Attia,
MD.
What are you on Facebook?
Um,
I don't know.
Probably.
Uh,
do you still have eating academy?
Is that the first left?
I don't,
I don't do a lot.
So Twitter's your most Twitter's private prominent and I've been berated into
doing something on Instagram.
I just can't cope at the moment.
The uh,
there's a way to connect the two.
I've tried it.
I don't like it.
I do them separately.
The Aa,
you don't really connect Twitter to the Instagram.
I think it's the other way around.
There's one way to connect to some of them somehow.
Yeah.
I just don't have enough pictures to show.
Right.
I don't have anything to,
don't you have a bunch of watches?
Yeah,
but I'm just going to watch the same watch every day.
I show that ring how you were explaining it could do like both pictures just on
the right for what if my,
what if my whole Instagram shtick became this like my blood glucose every
moment.
That'd be pretty cool.
And you kind of be interesting.
You could just,
you could just,
uh,
save that screen and posted up there.
So much work.
It's,
it's work.
It's hard labor to stave that thing and press submit to the,
it actually has a little switch that you can just make it go.
It's not that much work.
I'll think about it for somebody that swimming 18 miles and talk about too much
of work to post an Instagram picture.
All right.
Echo and I,
we are also present and accounted for on the interwebs on Twitter,
on Instagram and also if you're going to be looking around that Facebook,
he how are we going to be their
echo?
Is that Echo Charles and I am at jockowillink and again,
how would like to thank you Peter for coming on and more for everything you've
done
for me,
which really the way it's connected all together,
getting me through Kirk to Tim Ferriss,
which was the book and get me on Joe Rogan,
which led to this podcast.
It's been awesome.
So to you and to to doc Kirk Parsley for an introducing us,
but thank you and him for what you guys done for me.
So men and women in uniform out there holding the line.
Thanks for your service and your sacrifice to the police on the corner.
Fighting crime,
the firemen fighting fires.
Thanks for keeping us safe to the medical people in the medical professions,
like Peter,
doctors,
nurses,
physician's assistants,
he empties all of you working to save lives.
Thank you for your commitment to service,
and it's obviously a massive commitment when you hear about the hours and the
emotional trauma that it takes to go into any one of those industries and
services and to everybody else that's listening.
Thank you.
It's your communications,
your questions,
your participation,
your feedback,
and your spreading of the word that makes this possible.
And it's what makes this worthwhile.
So thank all of you for all of that.
Then finally,
thanks to all of you for getting out there
and getting after it.
Okay,
so until next time,
this is Dr Peter Attia,
an echo and Jocko
out.